Und jetzt geht's los.
Jetzt geht's los?
Jetzt geht's los.
Gut, dann geht's jetzt los.
Jetzt ist MOBA Max, da sind wir auch schwupps voll raus aus dieser Lethargie und schauen uns einfach mit großen Augen an.
Lethargie!
Ja, ich dachte ja, wir hätten keine Themen, aber dem ist ja wohl nicht so.
Nee, dem ist überhaupt nicht so.
Dann ist es im Gegenteil. Es ist eine Menge passiert, wie immer.
Dennis wird jetzt ungefähr die nächsten vier Stunden Flight Control spielen.
Ja, ich habe sehr viel Zeit damit verbracht, darüber nachzudenken, was für einen Macintosh ich mir kaufen soll. Ich bin echt hin und her gerissen. Ich habe mittlerweile, glaube ich, jedes Gerät einmal erwogen und bin keinen Schritt vorwärts gekommen.
Gut, dass man es zwei Schritte vor, einen zurück.
Jaja, man muss einfach mal gucken.
Ich will auch diesen Klon.
Genau, Mahoney, das ist hier so ein Toblerone-Klon, der noch aus unserer Schweizer Spenden-Schoko-Kisten-Aktion ist. Und wir haben so viel Schokolade bekommen, dass wir hier noch zwei Sendungen durchfressen können und unter Garantie mit vollem Magen. Vielleicht solltet ihr aber eure Mikrofone ein bisschen weiter bekalten. Naja, so was haben wir denn? Wollen wir irgendwie anfangen mit Macintosh? Oder wollen wir anfangen mit dem iPhone? Oder wollen wir anfangen mit Themen, die jenseits des Macintoshes und des iPhones sind?
Ich würde sagen, wir fangen mit dem Snowlappart an. Eigentlich wollte ich das schon vor zwei Wochen machen, habe ich aber verpeilt.
Okay, na dann, das ist doch ein gutes Argument.
Und dann habt ihr auch ein bisschen Zeit und so, um irgendwie eure Themen noch so ein bisschen vorzudenken.
Ich habe noch ein Thema, das hätte ich gar nicht.
Das kannst du dann nachher einwerfen. Na, was hast du denn rausgefunden?
Also, und zwar war ja die Frage, ob Snowlappart auf PowerPC läuft. Apple sagt, das läuft nicht, sondern Apple sagt, läuft nur auf Intel Max, was ja die ersten kamen 2006 raus. Das heißt, alle Rechner älter als dreieinhalb Jahre wären damit raus. So, jetzt ist aber so, dass auf der Snowlappart DVD oder auf dem Image, was man da bekommt, sagen wir mal hier die 380 von der WWDC, da ist der Installer, ist ein PowerPC Installer und wenn er loslegt und sich installiert, also auf einem Intel, weil anders geht's ja erstmal noch nicht ohne Tricksereien, dann installiert er halt Universal Binary Machkörne und auch der ganze Rest, also das komplette OS ist Universal. Das heißt, warum sollten die in den OS komplett den PowerPC Code mitliefern, wenn der dann nicht auf dem PowerPC läuft?
Naja, vielleicht machen sie das jetzt nur noch in diesen Beta-Phasen.
Ja, aber auch wozu? Weil man kann's ja, also ich hab's versucht auf dem PowerPC zu installieren, dann sagt der Installer gleich geht nicht. Dann habe ich auf einem Intel Mac installiert, auf einer extra Festplatte, die aber hier GUID war, also Grand Partition Scheme, wie auch immer, was halt die Intel Macs, wovon die booten können, aber die PowerPC leider nicht, habe ich vergessen. Jedenfalls sagt er dann auch, es geht nicht. Dann habe ich das nochmal gewechselt, habe diese Apple Partition Map benutzt, habe da das System drauf installieren wollen und dann sagt der Installer, das würde nicht gehen. Er unterstützt nur noch dieses neue Partition Schema. Okay, dann habe ich es auf das neue noch mal installiert und dann mit Carbon Copy Kloner auf ein Intel Partition Map geschoben, damit der PowerPC damit klarkommen würde. Und dann waren eigentlich meiner Meinung nach alle...
Ich habe verstanden, Intel.
Also mit Carbon Copy Kloner auf die Apple Partition rüberkopiert. So, dann waren eigentlich alle Bedingungen erfüllt, nämlich die Partition war richtig, ist alles Universal Binary und ist auf der richtigen Platte direkt angeschlossen und so weiter. Hat aber trotzdem nicht von gebootet. Also meine Erfahrungen oder meine Versuche sind alle kläglich gescheitert, aber mich wundert es trotzdem, warum sie PowerPC Code mit ausliefern, mit installieren und auch der Installer irgendwie alles PowerPC kann, wenn sie dann sagen, es läuft nicht auf dem PowerPC.
Ja vor allem, wo sie ja eigentlich auch gerade diesen smalleren Footprint als besonderes Feature preisen.
Ja, aber der smallere Footprint kommt eigentlich nicht von dem Weglassen von dem PowerPC. Also es ist ein bisschen so 10% oder vielleicht 15% oder so, aber nicht so wirklich. Es war schon, dass sie, habe ich auch schon mal auf irgendeinem Machackers Org irgendwann auf unserem drei Posts pro Jahr Blog gepostet, dass es da dran liegt, dass sie die Interface-Bilder-Files, die lagen dort immer ziemlich redundant vor und die haben die eine Version, die man nur als Developer braucht, haben sie weggelassen, sondern sind jetzt nur noch irgendwie ganz das Notdürftigste, was zum Programmstart gebraucht wird, liegt darum. Dadurch kann man die auch nicht mehr selber laden, das GUI ändern und wieder abspeichern. Das geht nämlich jetzt nicht mehr. Früher ging das. Haben sie ein bisschen zusammen gestrichen.
Also, ich denke, sie werden einfach es nicht mit ausliefern und es wird einfach am Ende nicht dabei sein.
Der PowerPC ist tot.
Ja, der PowerPC ist vorbei.
Habe sie ja so eine schöne Beerdigung?
Aber ich finde, sie hätten das noch mal rausbringen können. Ist jetzt nicht so schlimm.
Na doch, na klar ist das für sie schlimm.
Weil die Leute nicht upgraden und so.
Also ich glaube, dass die Installed Base PowerPC und zwar die Installed Base PowerPC, die jetzt überhaupt in Frage kämen.
Am Ende gab es schon irgendwie G5 mit Quad.
Ja, aber das heißt ja auch, wenn sie jetzt PowerPC droppen, dann droppen sie ja auch nicht nur diesen Prozessorsupport. Sie droppen ja auch den ganzen Systemlayout, Treiber, Chips, Bausteine, der ganze Schnaß, der da dran hängt, ihre Customchips und so weiter. All das, was halt an Treibern auch noch mit drin ist und was halt auch immer wieder mit getestet werden muss, dass es noch funktioniert, Regression-Test, blablabla. Das ist ja etwas, was auch Zeit und Geld frisst am Ende. Weil sie müssen es ja sicherstellen. Und natürlich werden sie, wenn sie einen OS-Release machen, das auf jedem Rechner testen. Also sollten sie zumindest. Machen sie wahrscheinlich auch. Weiß man natürlich nicht. Kann immer was schiefgehen, aber das ist ja gar keine Frage. Umso mehr Systeme du unterstützen musst. Und jetzt ist es ja so, dass die neuen Features, die sie jetzt preisen bei Snow Lappart, also die wirklich neu sind. Ich meine, was ist das schon? Das ist im Wesentlichen Exchange Support.
Also dieses Grand Central und QuickTime X und so.
Das ist aber kein Feature. Das ist jetzt nichts, wofür du wirklich das Upgrade brauchst. Das Upgrade ist wirklich dann für dich wichtig, wenn du jetzt explizit Vorteile hast von dieser Geschwindigkeitssteigerung. Die hast du aber ohnehin nur mit modernen Architekturen. Da hilft dir das auf dem G5 auch nicht viel. Na ja, es könnte theoretisch vielleicht unter Umständen und so, aber dann hast du ja auch noch den Trend, dass du eben auch bei den Applikationen natürlich alles auf...
Aber ich meine, gerade Exchange braucht doch keinen speziellen Hardware-Support. Das läuft auf dem Arm zur Not. Da müssen die doch nichts weiter supporten.
Die Leute, die danach schreien, die haben sich sowieso alle schon Intel Mac gekauft.
Ja das ist ekeler, dass die meistens alle Intel haben.
Schade, so schnell...
Genau, und deswegen können sie immer noch sagen, aber ansonsten, abgesehen von Exchange Support, also für denjenigen, der jetzt unbedingt noch seine alte Kiste betreiben will, gibt's auch noch 10.5. Das funktioniert da drauf, das hat weitgehend dasselbe Feature Set, ohne dass da jetzt irgendwas bahnbrechendes dabei wäre, was...
Nicht dabei wäre, was wir snoddelt, aber bei 10.5 eine neue Version raus, also nicht so ein Sicherheitsupdate, sondern eine neue Version, nachdem Snowlapp rausgekommen ist.
Wie du meinst, ein Feature-Upgrade?
Das ist ja kein Feature-Upgrade, nicht so wirklich. Also 10.5.10 auf 10.5.11 wäre ja kein Feature-Upgrade. Weil bisher hat ja es immer aufgehört.
Aber was für ein Release meinst du denn?
So die letzte Nummer in den drei Zahlen.
Das hängt dann einfach davon ab, was hier so für Bugs...
Weil bisher haben sie es noch nie gemacht. Und man könnte ja denken, dass vielleicht, wenn sie eine Architektur droppen, dass sie die dann halt noch...
Was haben sie noch nie gemacht?
Na, so eine Minor-Release rausgebracht, nachdem das neue OS da war.
Achso, dann haben sie es immer nur Security Updates.
Bist du dir jetzt ganz sicher, dass sie das noch nie gemacht haben? Aber sie haben zumindest Security Updates später auch nach.
Naja, die schon. So minimäßig. Und QuickTime und iTunes und so Sachen kommen immer noch. Aber so Minor-Release kamen nicht mehr.
Also wieder kann ich das vorhersagen noch...
Hängt davon ab, wie groß die Bugs sind, die sie noch finden. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass die noch... Also ich meine 10.5.7, 10.5.8 wird dann wahrscheinlich relativ stabil sein.
Sie haben immer noch kurz bevor das neue OS rausgebracht, haben sie sozusagen das letzte Minor-Release für das OS rausgebracht.
Na, 10.5.8 kommt jetzt auch demnächst.
Der Chat verweist hier noch auf OpenCL. Aber mit OpenCL ist es halt genauso wie mit Grand Central. Das ist halt ein Developer-Feature. Das muss halt überhaupt erst mal von Programmen aufgegriffen werden. Vorher ist es halt kein Feature.
Und die wären bestimmt... Also ein Feature, was extrem prozessorlastig ist und was so viel Rechenleistung braucht, da wird man sich wahrscheinlich nicht sagen, oh Gott, oh Gott, das muss noch auf einem alten G4 laufen.
Nein, OpenCL ist...
Das läuft auf der Grafikkarte, ist schon klar, aber...
Achso, du meinst, ja, das braucht eh eine neue GPU, die in den G5 gar nicht drin war. Also OpenCL macht überhaupt keinen Sinn auf PowerPC. Und auch auf den allerersten Interest-Druck.
Ich bin gespannt, was die Hacker sich einverlassen, um die Universal Binaries, die auf den letzten Betas jetzt hier WWDC Editions und so drauf ist, um das irgendwie noch auf ihren G5 oder so zum Laufen zu kriegen. Da gibt's ja diesen einen Typ.
Ja, aber nobody cares. Also ich meine, der PowerPC-Anteil, der ist einfach so geredet, bis das Ding noch draußen ist und dann vor allem, wenn dann wieder, also ich kann es verstehen.
Wir können ja eine Trauerfeier machen, offizielle für den PowerPC, wenn es so weit ist.
Es gibt wirklich andere Dinge, mit denen man sich unterhalten kann. Über die man sich unterhalten sollte.
Dann erzählen wir Geschichten über unseren ersten PowerPC Max und über unsere G3s. Hattet ihr einen?
Schnolebart. Sonst hab ich da nichts weiter zu erzählen.
Schnolebart.
Dann mach ich jetzt mal.
Aber man muss ja noch mal wiederholen, dass es nicht mehr so lange weg ist. September ist ja nun schon in 8 Wochen.
Das stimmt. Gab es eigentlich schon einen Termin?
Kein genaueren.
Naja, ich bin gespannt. Ich meine, das ist, wie ich schon sagte, meinetwegen können sie sich ruhig noch ein bisschen Zeit lassen. Ich hab's nie eilig damit.
Also ich hab mal mit rumgespielt, mit einer der späteren Versionen jetzt. Und ich glaube, das wird mal ein Release sein, wo man extrem viel Application Support braucht. Also zum Beispiel iStat Menus. So dieses, was ich immer nutze, damit man das in der Menüleiste anzeigt, was läuft einfach nicht mehr im Augenblick. Weil es davon auch keine 64-Bit-Version gibt. Ich nehme mal an.
Es läuft doch auch eine 32-Bit-Version.
Die 32-Bit-Version läuft nicht.
Ja, aber nicht weil sie 32-Bit ist, sondern weil sie irgendeine andere Inkompatibilität hat.
Ich vermute mal, dass wenn du oben in der Menüleiste drin rumzeichnen willst, dann ist das genauso wie mit Systemeinstellungen, ist ja auch so, dass wenn du die Systemeinstellungen startest, von iStat Menus, dann sagt er dir, ich hab jetzt das 32-Bit-Extension gefunden, darum muss ich jetzt mal die Systemeinstellungen in 32-Bit-Modus neu starten. Und ich nehme an, dass der Plug-in-Mechanismus für die Menüleiste relativ ähnlich aussehen wird. Wenn die Menüleiste als 64-Bit-Prozess läuft und irgendwie welches Thread als 32-Bit, dann dürfte das dazu Inkompatibilitäten führen.
Dein Rechner bootet ja auch das Snowlapp schon richtig in 64-Bit-Modus. Meiner nehme ich irgendwie noch nicht, obwohl er 64-Bit kann. Da bin ich auch gespannt, welche Architekturen oder Plattformen...
Also, da muss man jetzt mal sagen, von welchen Modellen du redest.
Also das ist ja das jetzt nicht mehr aktuelle MacBook Pro.
Also du hast schon eins mit Glas und Schwarz und du hast noch so ein silbernes.
Aber auch das vorherige hätte schon einen 64-Bit-Modus. Also das letzte...
Ich will ja nur sagen, es handelt sich um eine unterschiedliche Generation hier.
Meins ist das erste, was irgendwie 64-Bit-Support hat, aber es wird von Snowlapp nicht unterstützt bisher, obwohl es möglich wäre. Aber ich könnte mir auch gut vorstellen, dass Apple das nicht mehr macht.
Ja, und was... Also es ist auf jeden Fall macht... Also dieses mit dem... Mit dem ins Dock reinklicken, um dein Exposé zu starten, ist eine sehr schöne Sache.
Ja, du hast also die Raum 194 getestet?
Ja.
Okay, das werden wir reden, mal später.
Die kommt per Software-Update. Wenn man die WWDC-Version hat, dann kann man per Software-Update.
Richtig?
Schöne neue Welt. Schöne neue Welt.
Denn es fährt sein Rechner runter. Aber eben, was ich als extrem negativ bemerkt habe, ist, es gibt eben mit bestehenden Programmen sehr, sehr viele Inkompatibilitäten. Also gerade in diesem 64-Bit-Bereich stand da einiges noch nicht so ganz zu klappen, wie es sollte. Da werden einige Updates noch kommen müssen.
Es sind ja auch noch zwei Monate Zeit. Also ich meine, das wäre jetzt nicht das erste Mal, dass das System ein, zwei Monate vor Release einen wackeligen Eindruck macht und dann kriegen sie es trotzdem hin.
Also wie gesagt, das System war es gar nicht. Sondern es war wirklich.
Man weiß ja immer nicht, was es war. Kann ja irgendwas sein, was dazu wackelt reinführt.
Ich glaube, an dem Köln machen die jetzt schon nicht mehr viel. Das haben die alles schon bombenfest.
Das will man hoffen.
Es kommen nur noch ein paar Design-Änderungen oder ein paar optische Geschichten, wo sie ein bisschen noch justieren, machen und tun und so. Noch ein paar Bugs fixen, aber in vier Wochen muss es nicht fertig sein. Dann muss der Zeug zum Presswerk und dann geht's los.
Na gut, wollen wir noch weiter hier orakelen? Ich finde das ein bisschen unproduktiv. Wir haben das jetzt zur Kenntnis genommen, dass PowerPC zwar noch mit ausgeliefert wird, aber wir sind alle der Meinung, das wird nicht kommen. Und so ist das dann. Ja, dann, was ich ganz interessant fand, ist die Diskussion, die ich leider jetzt auch nur so mit anderthalb Ohren und Augen verfolgt habe, rund um Videosupport in HTML5, beziehungsweise den entsprechenden Support in den Browsern. Jetzt haben wir ja mit Safari 4 und mit Firefox 3.5 zwei Browser auf dem Markt, die zumindest so weitgehend HTML5 im Fokus haben. Ich will jetzt mal nicht davon sprechen, dass sie compliant sind. Da HTML5 selber noch ein Moving Target ist, ist das eh noch ein bisschen offen. Aber ich denke, da zeichnet sich was ab. Was natürlich der größte Vorteil davon ist, dass es jetzt Audio und Video auch als Tag gibt, als Element in HTML.
Genau, aber sie haben sich nicht auf ein Videoformat einigen können.
Genau, sie haben sich nicht auf ein Videoformat einigen können. Da ging es auch hoch her in den entsprechenden Standardsitzungen. Es gab da verschiedene Fraktionen. Da gab es so Fraktionen, die waren halt der Meinung, diese Formate, die vom W3C unterstützt werden, die müssen halt frei sein und Patentrecht und balala. Das ist die übliche Position. Und demgegenüber dann halt die auch übliche Position. Wir wollen lieber was haben, wo wir wissen, woran wir sind, als etwas, wo wir nicht wissen, woran wir sind. Und außerdem ist auch MPEG 4 sowieso der Industriestandard und das gibt es irgendwie alles in Hardware und den Rest gibt es irgendwie nicht in Hardware. Und wenn wir jetzt irgendwie beides unterstützen, dann verwässern wir das und so. Ich weiß jetzt, ich habe jetzt gar nicht geguckt, was eigentlich jetzt konkret derzeit im Entwurf steht, inwieweit die sich eigentlich wirklich auf einen Kodec festlegen. Ich vermute mal, sie tun es einfach gar nicht, sondern du kannst halt in dem HTML deine Media-Types da definieren, also deine Mime-Types irgendwie mit dazuschmeißen und dann sagen hier, das ist für den und das ist für den Type. Und dann muss man halt sehen, wie man klarkommt. Es gibt da so eine schöne Seite, wo jemand mal so gezeigt hat, wie man da eben Fallback-mäßig das so machen kann. Das heißt, wenn man seine Dateien generell in MPEG 4H 264 und auch in Okteora, also jetzt im Falle von Video, bereithält, dann kann man eben seine Seite auch schon so trimmen, dass dann entweder das eine oder das andere kommt und dann hat er auch noch irgendwie mit JavaScript so einen Hack eingebaut. Das sollte eben beides nicht unterstützt werden, sozusagen überhaupt gar kein expliziter Tech-Support, dann Fallback auf Flash und wie gewohnt. Wobei du ja dann wiederum gucken kannst, hab ich irgendwie mindestens Flash 9, dann kannst du ja auch H264 spielen.
Genau, oder ansonsten FLV-Version.
Und ansonsten müsstest du noch FLV machen, aber ich denke, das mit dem FLV, das ist jetzt auch zu Ende.
Also das läuft jetzt aus. Also an diesem HTML5 gibt es jetzt in diesen Randbereichen, das gefällt mir irgendwie nicht so richtig gut. Also da hat mich mal jemand drauf gestoßen, da bin ich per Twitter drauf gestoßen, da gibt es ja auch diese SQL-Datenbanken in HTML5. Und da ist nirgendwo spezifiziert, was dieser SQL-Standard, den die verwenden. Im Wesentlichen schmeißen die da alle in eine SQLite-Datenbank rein. Und nirgendwo steht, diese Befehle werden unterstützt, wie Stored Procedures funktionieren, was da überhaupt geht und so, sondern es ist ein wesentliches Feature Set von SQLite 3 oder was die eben gerade reinschmeißen. Und in dem Moment lässt sich das W3C-Controller ziemlich komplett die Kontrolle darüber nehmen, was für Features werden wir unterstützen. Weil wenn jetzt SQLite 4 kommt und das dann neue Features unterstützt, kann ich die dann als Web-Entwickler einfach so nutzen. Wann werden die in Firefox drin sein, wann werden die in Safari sein. Wenn Microsoft irgendwann mal einen Internet Explorer erweitert, nehmen wir mal an, die bauen dann tatsächlich auch diese Datenbank ein, diese kleinseitige, dann haben die nichts, woran sie sich orientieren können. Dann können die entweder sagen, wir schmeißen auch SQLite in unseren Browser rein. Oder sie müssen halt alle Features von SQLite nachimplementieren. Weil es gibt keine offizielle Dokumentation, wie diese Datenbanken in HTML5 zu funktionieren haben. Und so ähnlich sieht es auch ein bisschen mit den Videoformaten aus. Und das ist alles ein bisschen schwammig. Da haben sich glaube ich ein bisschen viel auf einen Schlag vorgenommen.
Gut, aber ich meine, daran wird es jetzt nicht scheitern. HTML5 bringt einfach so viele Verbesserungen mit sich, wo es eh noch ein, zwei Jahre dauern wird, bis die alle aufgenommen werden.
Das wird daran nicht scheitern, aber es wird das Ganze natürlich ein bisschen problematischer machen. Also für die Zukunft dann.
Vielleicht ist es natürlich gut, wenn ihr sich nicht einigen könnt, oder?
Könnte man so sagen, ja. Aber ich denke, die Uhr von Flash, die tickt einfach.
Genau. Irgendjemand schreibt hier gerade auf dem Chat so schön, bei Flash weiß man sehr gut, welche Codex an Bord sind. Da kann man gucken, habe ich Flash 9, habe ich Flash 10, habe ich Flash 8, dann kann ich die Version und die Version liefern. Beim Browser hat man jetzt durch dieses nicht sich auf ein Videoformat einigen können.
Ja, also klar, das ist halt der Vorteil eines geschlossenen Systems, aber wir wissen auch, was der Vorteil eines offenen Systems ist und am Ende wird sich halt das offene System durchsetzen. Das ist so. Hoffen wir's.
Klick to Flash.
Naja, was jetzt aber ganz interessant ist, ist halt der Browsersupport. Firefox macht halt nur Okteura. Und... Safari macht nur H264. Und Chrome macht beides. Naja, schlau von Chrome spiegelt auf jeden Fall eine sehr unterschiedliche Kultur wieder so. Also Apple sagt...
Na, Apple hat das Format, das sie forcieren wollen. Das ist ganz klar.
Na, was heißt Apple hat das Format? Es handelt sich halt einfach um den Standard. Punkt.
Naja, aber die haben ja auch hier... Das pushen sie ja schon eine ganze Weile, diesen Standard.
Klar, Apple pusht immer Standards. Das ist ja nichts Neues.
Manchmal finden sie auch eigene Standards, wie zum Beispiel diesen Mini-Displayport hier an meinem MacBook Pro. Und das ist dann nur so teilweise...
Egal, egal.
Das ist jetzt eine müßige Diskussion. Der ist ja freigegeben.
Das Apple natürlich nur ihren iPod-Codec sozusagen, ihren iPod, iPhone, iTunes-Codec unterstützt, ist ja nachvollziehbar.
Was meint ihr denn mit iPod-Codec? Das ist einfach... Es gibt de facto derzeit einfach nur einen Videocodec, der nennenswerte Industrieunterstützung hat in Form von Software, Lizenzen und Hardware.
Und das ist Hardware.
Also ich sage nicht, das ist toll. Ich sage nur, so ist das. Das ist halt einfach Fakt. Du kannst dir einfach die Hardware kaufen, da schmeißt du es rein, jede Grafikkarte macht das und so. Ich könnte mir allerdings auch vorstellen, dass ich jetzt im Rahmen von OpenCL schnell solche Sachen... Also es müsste ja eigentlich problemlos möglich sein, einen hardwarebasierten Performanten, Theora, Encoder und vor allem auch Decoder zu machen, der in der Grafikkarte läuft. Den schreibt man dann einfach in OpenCL. Und dann kann der eben problemlos auch auf einer beliebigen Hardware, also zumindest auf einer beliebigen Desktop-Hardware und vielleicht über kurz oder lang auch irgendwann in so einem iPhone, wenn es erstmal OpenCL kann, naja. Und alternativer Codex unterstützen. Kann man den Decoder auch so laufen lassen. Na ja, wenn das iPhone OpenCL macht und das ein offenes API ist, dann ist das halt so. Also das ist jetzt nur so eine Mutmaßung, dass ihr mir sehr gut vorstellen könntet, dass eben dieses Problem des mangelnden Hardware-Supports durch die Hintertür mit OpenCL sich wieder erledigt. Und ich weiß auch nicht, welche Auswirkungen das hat. Na ja, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Ich denke, wir werden mit beiden leben müssen. Also ich meine, immerhin reduziert sich es jetzt auf zwei Varianten. Was ja auch noch ein großes Fragezeichen ist, obwohl mir leider mangels Zeit und Kontakten immer noch keine wirkliche Erklärung über den Tisch gelaufen ist, diese Lizenzgeschichte. Also angeblich ist es ja so, dass 2010 sich die Lizenzierung von H264 dahingehend ändert, dass man eben auch als Content-Anbieter Lizenzzahlungen zu leisten hat unter bestimmten Umständen. Und das schließt ein Streaming, das schließt aber auch ein Download ab einer bestimmten Menge. Und ich glaube, die Menge ist so bei 250.000 Items. Jetzt kann ich das nur so wiedergeben, wie ich das so im Hirn kleben habe. Es finden sich auch auf den entsprechenden Wikipedia-Seiten und so weiter Hinweise. Aber ich habe einfach bisher noch wirklich keine verlassbare Referenz gefunden, wo das mal wirklich aufgedröselt wurde, ob die das ernst meinen oder nicht. Ich meine, was soll das heißen? Soll das heißen, dass man, wenn man jetzt einen Videopodcast macht mit H264 und der läuft irgendwie gut, ja, meine 250.000 ist so unrealistisch nicht. Da gibt es eine Menge, die werden solche Downloads einfach haben, dass man dann eben für die Verwendung dieses Formates noch Kohle abdrücken muss und das dann vielleicht auch noch im Verhältnis zu den Downloads, auch wenn es kostenlos ist.
Ist das der Grund, warum der Firefox das nicht macht?
Naja, ich meine, warum die Open-Source-Szene hinter Tiora steht, ist ja vollkommen klar.
Ja, weil sie auch keine Bock auf so eine Lizenzgeschichte haben.
Genau, weil sie keinen Bock haben auf Lizenzen, weil sie überhaupt keinen Bock haben auf in irgendeiner Form mit Fallstricken ausgestattete Technologie. Und das ist ja auch vollkommen nachvollziehbar und korrekt. Zuletzt war es ja auch so, dass sie wohl signifikante Verbesserungen auch in ihrem Encoder gemacht haben, sodass sie eben die strukturellen Nachteile, die sie gegenüber H264 haben, so mit mangelnden Bi-Frames und so weiter, haben auch zumindest, naja, verbessern können, die Unterschiede schmälern können. Ich habe da nur so ein paar, naja, eher oberflächliche Vergleiche gesehen, die aber zumindest behauptet haben, naja, vielleicht das ist nicht geworden. Kann man auch schon mitarbeiten. Ich denke auch, dass es am Ende des Tages nicht wirklich darauf ankommt, dass man zwei Codecs immer mit ein und derselben Bitrate vergleichen muss. Ich meine, bei den großen Variablen und großen Bandbreiten, also Variablen, Gesamtgrößen der Videos, dann ist es einem auch irgendwann egal, ob man da jetzt nochmal einen Megabyte oder zwei mehr lädt. Und wenn es dann eben einfach diesen Tipping-Point erreicht, dass dann eben die Qualität auch okay ist, auch wenn vielleicht eigentlich der Encoder oder Decoder schlechter ist, dann interessiert es auch keinen mehr. Und das Performance-Problem ist natürlich ein echtes Problem, weil auf dem iPhone, ganz klar, da willst du halt keinen Software-Decoder haben. Das ist halt einfach mal, das geht einfach nicht mit so einer CPU. Das wird vielleicht irgendwann mal gehen mit so einer CPU, weil so richtig mega langsam ist ja nicht. Aber derzeit ist halt der Vorteil natürlich, wenn du H264 inkodetest, dann spielt das hier der Stein direkt ab und gut ist. Habt ihr eigentlich schon ein iPhone 3GS in der Hand gehabt?
Ja, ich nicht.
Also, ich hatte nur ein paar Minuten damit.
Ich hatte auch nur ein paar Minuten. Was, also Johnny von Spreeblick, der hat sich das natürlich sofort wieder geholt. Was er meint, was das beste Feature wäre, das ist eins, was überhaupt nicht erwähnt worden ist, und zwar dieses neue Display. Dieses Oleophobik. Dieses Oleophobik.
Es gibt schon Gerüchte, dass es sich bei viel Benutzung irgendwie weggeht.
Abnutzt.
Ach, das sozusagen, das kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das dann irgendwie sich erledigt. Aber auf jeden Fall soll es so wirklich sein, zumindest am Anfang, wenn du da Dreck drauf hast, du wirst es einmal kurz auf der Hose ab und das ist wieder sauber wie am ersten Tag. Und ansonsten ist es natürlich schneller, das ist natürlich auch, ist ja, also man, ist eine merkliche Geschwindigkeit. Also wenn man zwei iPhones nebeneinander legt, das alte, ich hatte auch schon mal in so einer Hand, das alte und das neue und dann irgendein Programm startet, dann ist es auf dem, also gerade bei so Programmen wie dem SMS-Programm oder Tweety oder sowas, dann ist es genau dieser Unterschied zwischen nervig und hey, das ist noch okay schnell.
Das war verdammt schnell, ich hab irgendwie Google Earth damit getestet.
Das hab ich auch gemacht.
Normalerweise, wenn das schon an die Erde so ranzoomt, dann macht es immer so ruck, ruck, ruck. Und bei dem 3G ist es so smooth rangezoomt und es war einfach viel flottert, viel schneller nachgeladen. Also die Küchenigkeit war schon erstaunlich.
Ich denke auch und ich merk jetzt auch, dass der Speed eigentlich das ist, was mich mit dem 3G am meisten nervt. Ich warte halt einfach 3-4 Sekunden, damit sich irgendwas startet und wenn das fixer gehen würde, das wäre schon doch ein erheblicher Usability-Gewinn. Find ich. Trotzdem auf den ersten Blick ist irgendwie nichts anderes. Aber ich hab dann auch den Kompass mal kurz ausprobiert. Das funktioniert soweit und dann hast du ja dann auch noch in der Maps eben diese Möglichkeit automatisch zu rotieren, wofür das zum Beispiel super cool ist, wenn du in so einem Park sitzt und bist nur so von Bäumen umgeben. Siehst halt eigentlich gar nichts. Willst aber wissen, hinter welchem Baum jetzt, keine Ahnung, der Spielplatz der Kiosk, der Supermarkt ist, dann schaltest du halt einfach auf den Satelliten-View und dann dreht sich eben das Teil vor deinen Augen einfach genau so, wie du jetzt gerade guckst. Und dann weißt du, ah, alles klar, da muss ich durch die Büsche durch, wo du sonst halt überhaupt nicht wüsstest, wo im Grunde ist.
Warst du auch nicht bei den Pfadfindern, wa?
Klar war ich, ich war ja vor Waldorfschule mein Freund. Na, da ist man schon so ein bisschen naturverbunden.
Na dann weißt du doch immer, wo welche Richtung ist.
Gut raus geredet.
Was ich noch getestet hab, ist Videos aufnehmen.
Ahja, das hab ich auch kurz gemacht. Man kann ja auch bei den Videos diese Schärfe machen.
Das hab ich nicht getestet, aber so.
Man kann einfach hinklicken, wo es scharf sein soll. Die Belichtung passt sich an und natürlich auch der Fokus.
Das mit der Belichtung wussten erst mal viele noch nicht, dass man auch, dass er dann die Belichtung ändert. Aber es war, also ich fand es erstaunlich, so smooth die Aufnahme und auch das Sucherbild. Also man sieht ja währenddessen schon die ganze Zeit was aufgenommen wird und es war auch sehr flüssig. Also ich fand es beeindruckt.
Ja, was mir gerade in dem Zusammenhang einfällt ist, ich hab ja letztes Mal großspruchig behauptet, dass in zwei Wochen ist für das Gejailbreak des 3G, der Hack da, mit dem man einfach so Videos gucken kann. Das sah ja zwischendurch mal so aus, als ob es tatsächlich hinhauen könnte. Aber es gibt irgendwie, haben wir es geschafft, einen Schalter zu finden, mit dem man es umdrehen kann. Der funktioniert aber noch nicht so richtig. Also man kann da mit Videos aufnehmen, aber es ist noch keine wirkliche Lösung, die man sich jetzt bei Sydia installieren kann oder auch will, soweit ich das mitbekommen habe bisher. Insofern schuldigt da jemand ein Bier, fürchte ich. Aber ich gebe die Hoffnung noch nicht auf, dass das noch kommen wird.
Weißt du, auf wem du ein Bier schuldest?
Dem ist Pro. Ich.
Aber ich hab ihm dann auch wieder gefolgt. Jaja, mehr können wir nicht dazu sagen. Das ist ein bisschen schade, ne, eigentlich.
Zum neuen 3G.
Aber die Frage ist, kauft man sich jetzt so einen Teil oder nicht?
Also ich hab schon, mir wurde von einem Fellow-Follower angeboten, dass er mir eins aus Belgien mitbringt.
Ja, ich hab auch gerade eine größere Timing an Leuten, die kurz davor ist, nach Italien aufzubreiten.
Na ist er auch hingefahren, aber die hatten nur zwei und er war halt mit einem Kumpel unterwegs und deswegen haben die halt die beiden natürlich erst mal genommen. Weil ja, hab ich sozusagen Pech gehabt. Aber er fährt nochmal und ich hab noch eine zweite Chance und ich hoffe, es klappt und ich bedanke mich jetzt schon mal.
Wie frei ist denn das Belgien-Phone?
Na so wie das Italienische. Unlocked halt.
Komplett ohne Strings attached?
Ja, 675 Euro.
Ist noch einen Zacken billiger als in Italien, ne?
Wie was?
675 in Belgien.
Wieso, was kostet das in Italien?
719 bei Tim und 699 bei Apple.
Ach.
Das sind 25 Euro.
Und da muss man jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr erzählen, wenn wir schon mal dabei sind.
Das heißt, hier die Jungs in Aachen und so? Die können auch mal eben überjätten, ne? Die Mädels vor allem.
Ich hab eine Bekannte in Aachen. Das heißt, wenn jetzt mit meinem Fellow, Follower...
Ich dachte jetzt Mädels werden zuerst bedient in den Läden oder so.
Bestimmt auch.
Aber wie ist denn das? Also es gibt die Unlocked, aber es gibt sie auch komplett vertragsfrei. Oder muss man da noch irgendwie...
Ja, du gehst rein und sagst, du willst ein iPhone haben, dann kriegst du das Unlocked, vertragsfrei und kannst wieder gehen.
Ohne Karte.
Und bei Tim in Italien, also da kriegst du es für 719 auch Unlocked und du kriegst ein 5 Euro...
Sag doch einfach mal Telekom Italia, das find ich irgendwie toller.
Steht immer Tim da.
Ich weiß.
Eigentlich müsstest du ja bei dem Vertrag abschließen.
Back to Thema. Da kriegst du es für 719 und aber noch eine 5 Euro, wie heißt das hier, so eine Prepaid-Karte. 5 Euro, wow.
Belgien.
In Italien war das jetzt. Ja, also ich krieg... Meins wird geschoppt am 11. wenn's klappt und mitgebracht krieg ich's am 17.
Hm, na ich bin mir einfach noch gerade nicht so sicher, ob's den Aufpreis mir wert ist.
Also für mich ist es wert, weil ich hab ja noch hier das erste First-Generation-iPhone.
Ja klar, das ist natürlich...
Da lohnt sich das, da gibt es so viele Sachen. Genau, jetzt wollte ich noch was zu dem Unlocked erklären. Ja. Und zwar ist es halt nicht nur das Unlocking, was man braucht, sondern wie jetzt viele festgestellt haben, die einen Unlocked, also hier so ein, wie sagt man, illegal Unlocked, nee, ist ja nicht illegal, aber nicht offiziell Unlocked Telefon haben, also iPhone, die können dieses Push-Notification nicht benutzen, weil die ID, die für das Aktivieren irgendwie benutzt wird, die wird auch für die Push-Notification benutzt. Was ja klar ist, weil es ja ein Server von Apple, der irgendwie auf irgendeiner Basis eine ID irgendwie arbeitet und diese ID ist wohl wieder abhängig von der Aktivierung, weil wenn Apple sozusagen dein Phone nicht kennt, dann machen sie auch kein Push-Notification mit dir. Deswegen habe ich gerade keinen Push-Notification.
Aber da gibt es da ja schon eine Lösung für.
Gibt es schon?
Und da gibt es eine Lösung vom Dev-Team.
Nee, sie wollten eine suchen, sie haben doch keine gefunden.
Oh, da gibt es eine Lösung vom Dev-Team.
Oh, really? Ich habe die ganze Zeit aufgepasst, da war nichts. Außer da kam so schnell News, dass ich irgendwie eine verpasst habe.
Ich kann bestimmt jemanden posten. Also ich habe...
Jetzt findet er es nicht, das ist ja typisch. Na, wir werden ja sehen gleich, was hier so kommt. Ich habe bisher jedenfalls nichts gesehen und man muss da zumindest auch noch mal was hacken. Was aber schwer sein könnte, weil es kann sein, dass du ja irgendwie bei Apple eine ID haben musst. Weil Apple weiß ja, welche Telefone aktiviert sind und welche nicht. Deswegen könnte das eigentlich sein, dass sie das wirklich wasserdicht hinkriegen, wenn sie sich anregen. Dann rede ich ja hier schon wieder Blödsinn. Na, bis vor fünf Minuten war es so.
Nicht so richtig. Ich weiß nicht, was man da genau machen muss. Weil ich brauche das ja gar nicht auf meinem Kanal.
Dann werde ich mal live irgendwie testen, dann werde ich es ja sehen, wenn es jetzt nicht einschätzt.
Also danach sollte YouTube gehen und Push. Kannst du ja mal irgendwo tauchte, der hier.
Ja, kannst du ja mal mir rüber posten, irgendwie in der Bauchure mäßig. Was wollte ich noch sagen?
Ich finde ja, man sollte sich einfach so ein Telefon an Lock kaufen oder es bleiben lassen.
Das ist ja meine Rede, deswegen mache ich das ja auch jetzt.
Also bei der ersten Generation, die gab es ja noch.
Übrigens kriegt man für so erste Generation, also für meins hier, bei eBay noch immer locker 200 Euro. Alle verrückt.
Ja, ich hoffe nur, dass ich irgendwie mit meinem alten 3G noch irgendwas machen kann, weil mein Teil hat eine Macke.
Welche?
Die Macke ist, dass mein Kopfhörerausgang irgendwie so ein bisschen Kontaktprobleme hat. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht hört uns ja auch irgendein, irgendjemand, der so iPhone-Service macht und hat da irgendwie eine gute Idee, wie man das reparieren kann.
Also ich hatte bei meinem alten iPhone auch Probleme mit dem Kopfhörerausgang regelmäßig mal. Und zwar, dass er, wenn ich einen Kopfhörer reingesteckt habe, er oft nicht umgeschaltet hat. Also dass es trotzdem über den Lautsprecher kam, auch wenn ich einen Kopfhörer dran hatte, wenn ich zum Beispiel angerufen wurde. Und umgekehrt teilweise, das ist natürlich dann noch nerviger, wenn der Kopfhörer rausgezogen war, dass ich es dann nicht über das Telefon, dass es dann glaubt, dass der Kopfhörer immer noch angeschlossen sei. Dagegen hilft ein bisschen Alkohol und einem Wattestäbchen, also ein abgeschnittenes Wattestäbchen, so mal vorsichtig sauber machen im Kopfhörerausgang.
Ja, nee, es ist keine reine Kontaktprobleme, das habe ich natürlich alles schon gemacht. Es ist irgendwie, ich habe so das Gefühl, dass es irgendwie so ein bisschen verbogen, irgendwas ist deformiert. Weil es ist auch so, ich habe mit unterschiedlichen Kopfhörern unterschiedlich gute Ergebnisse. Es gibt welche, die gehen überhaupt nicht. Und es gibt welche, mit denen geht es halt noch ganz gut.
Aber die kann man auch ganz leicht öffnen oder nicht, oder?
Ich wüsste nicht, wie.
Also ich habe mir so die beiden Schrauben und dann irgendwie das Display mit so einem Saugknopf irgendwie so hochziehen.
Ja, ich habe mir so ein Take-Apart-Video angeschaut. Das ist schon ein länglicher Prozess und ist natürlich auch mal wieder potenziell garantieverseuchend, wobei das jetzt bei dem Italien-Phone eh egal ist, weil ich glaube ich meinen Beleg verloren habe, beziehungsweise der war in irgendeiner Kiste.
Und du müsstest dann sowieso nach Italien.
Das habe ich bei meinem Sohn mal gesehen, aber ohne den Beleg. It's gone.
Du solltest es auf jeden Fall nicht in den Kopfhörer machen, weil dann schlägt der, obwohl deine Garantie ist eh durch, deswegen ist es egal. Weil sonst schlägt der Feuchtigkeitssensor ja an. Vielleicht wird er dann blau.
Dann müsste er jetzt schon mal etwas blau sein, wa?
Ist das nicht rot, der Punkt?
Ich sehe hier überhaupt nichts, um ehrlich zu sein.
Also man soll wohl ziemlich deutlich den roten Punkt sehen, wenn man ihn sieht.
Okay, dann ist hier keiner.
Also gucken sie mal rein, was sie sehen sollen für eine Fahre.
Genau, hier ist wieder ein ganz Schlaumchat. Der sagt natürlich, dass es, außer du benutzt 100% Alkohol, ist natürlich da auch immer Wasser mit drin in der Alkohol. Aber okay, man kann ja 100% benutzen. Also das Wasser, Quatsch ist Alkohol, hydroskopisch, also zieht das Wasser an?
Ich glaub schon.
Ist egal.
Keine Ahnung, auf jeden Fall hab ich so ein Reinigungsalkohol verwendet. Also ich hab jetzt nicht irgendwo da kein Wodka reingegossen, sondern ich hab da einfach so Haushaltsalkohol, den man halt so nimmt, ne? So, das war's aber nicht. Und klar, ich könnte Kontaktbrechen nochmal ausprobieren, aber ich glaub halt nicht, dass es klar ran liegt.
Glaub ich auch nicht, das ist ein physikalisches Problem, oder?
Es scheint mir irgendwie einfach so etwas diffumiert zu sein. Ich muss auch sagen, ich hab den wirklich viel benutzt. Na gut, aber jetzt mit Bluetooth ist es natürlich wiederum benutzbarer geworden. Wobei ich da vielleicht auch nochmal als Nachtrag zu meinem Nokia-Review hier, diesen BH604-Teil, was ich da habe, das, was ich am Anfang hatte, ist jetzt auch wiedergekehrt. Also ich hab in 70 Prozent der Fälle funktioniert diese Play-Pause-Funktion nicht. Und ich weiß nicht, woran es liegt.
Okay.
Also lass mal booten und dann geht's wieder. Und dann mal booten und dann geht's wieder nicht. Und dann geht's ein paar Tage nicht. Und dann geht's wieder ein paar Tage. Also es ist irgendwie total ominös.
Klickt nach einem Fix für 3.1, oder?
Wenn's, ja, kann natürlich, also kann natürlich beide Seiten sein. Das kann sein, dass das Telefon unter bestimmten Umständen, dass diese Taste nicht funktioniert. Keine Ahnung, was nicht konformes rüber schickt, kann natürlich auch einfach ein Bug im iPhone OS sein. Was ich mal vermuten würde, dass es eher das ist. Ja, 3.1 ist ja auch schon unterwegs, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Zumindest gibt es schon so erste Versionen und da kommt ja auch, also da fassen sie auf jeden Fall noch mal eine Menge an, so mit Voice-Recording über Bluetooth und so weiter. Also dem Teil widmen sie ohnehin da noch eine gewisse Aufmerksamkeit. Von daher hab ich da noch eine Versicht, dass sich das verbessert.
Da kommen auch neue OpenGL Funktionen oder Updates oder OpenCL auch. Ich glaube OpenGL und Video machen so eine Menge, eine API und so.
Na ja, Video steht überhaupt zur Verfügung für Apps.
Was heißt Video steht zur Verfügung?
Bisher kann nur die Kamera-Applikation auf die Video-API zugreifen.
Also, als ich das verstanden habe, kannst du auf die Videos zugreifen.
Das hab ich auch verstanden.
Nur auf die Videos? Da kann man auch aufzeichnen.
Gute Frage.
I don't know, aber was ich gehört habe, ist, dass es eine API gibt, um auf die Videos zuzugreifen.
Was ein hübsches Detail ist, was ich ganz gerne mag, ist, dass man endlich Telefonnummern im Telefonprogramm pasten kann.
Ja, haben sie auch gefixt.
Also, und zwar war das ja bisher so, wenn man einfach auf einer Weltsite hat zum Beispiel die Telefonnummer von irgendjemanden rausgesucht, hat die per Copy und Paste kopiert und dann hatte man so eine Zwischenablage und damit konnte die nicht wählen. Und das geht, weil in diesem Nummernfeld kann man nichts einsetzen. Und dann musste man immer einen leeren Kontakt anlegen, da die Nummer rein posten und diese Nummer dann anwählen. Das ging dann zwar. Oder eine leere Mail anlegen und die dann... und so was. Aber jetzt kann man direkt ins Nummernfeld posten. Kleines Hübschelsdetail, wie ich finde.
Ich will noch mal kurz einen Nachtrag machen zu dem Push-Notification-Fix, den du mir hier gepostet hast. Also so wie das da aussieht, braucht man ein Telefon, was irgendwie offiziell Apple irgendwie ist. Und muss ich dort irgendwelche Zerts klauen, was sich aber daraus schließt, ist, dass sich zwei dann die gleiche ID bei dem Push-Notification-Dienst teilen und eventuell dann bei beiden die eins bei der Mail auftaucht oder bei der Jummer-Nachricht oder irgendwie so, weil die ja eventuell auf der gleichen Nachricht...
Habt ihr denn jetzt schon mal Push irgendwie erfolgreich getestet? Womit?
Also ich hab einen sehr hübschen, ich hab zwei Instant Messages durchgetestet, die beide können. Das ist einmal IM Plus 3.0 für 8 Euro und einmal...
Haben wir da letztes Mal schon drüber geredet?
Nee, letztes Mal gab es das noch nicht.
Ah, genau.
Letztes Mal gab es noch die alte Version. Und die kam ein paar Stunden später oder sowas. Ich weiß nicht, ob sogar noch in derselben Nacht. Und das funktioniert. Also am Anfang hat es ein bisschen gezickt, aber es funktioniert eigentlich erst noch nicht zuverlässig. Der Akku wird dadurch deutlich schneller leer. Das kriegt man wirklich mit. Also ich muss mich jetzt genauso wahrscheinlich wie wenn man ein Push-Mail aktiviert hat. Mein Akku hält jetzt den Tag durch, aber viel länger auch nicht. Also wenn ich vorhabe, nicht zu Hause überhand zu übernachten, dann sollte ich auch ein Ladegerät dabei haben. Aber ansonsten ist das echt eine schicke Sache. Du kannst mich einfach mal im Chat beenden und du kannst mich einfach mal anchatten und dann müsste hier mal eine Push-Notification kommen.
Und wenn es dann noch läuft. Die sind ja auch zeitbegrenzt, oder? Bei AIM war das Maximum 24 Stunden.
Warte mal kurz, dann geh ich mal kurz online, dann geh ich danach wieder offline.
Oder war doch so, dass es nur für so eine, also bis maximal 24 Stunden, da diesen Notification-Dienst anwählt, oder geht auch unendlich?
Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt. Also man kann, ich glaube, man kann bei B-Jive, macht das nicht unendlich, aber ich starte es dann einfach einmal am Tag oder irgendwie sowas. Es lockt da sich gerade ein. Das wäre natürlich ein schöner Vorführeffekt, wenn es jetzt gerade langsam wäre.
Also was man ja auf jeden Fall noch mal betonen sollte, diese Dienste, die dann jetzt für Jabber Push-Modification machen.
Das muss nicht online sein, oder? Also nicht online, aber abwesend.
Ja, du bist quasi nicht, aber du bist auf jeden Fall nicht mehr offline. So, jetzt tippe ich mal was schönes.
Wie Sie sehen, sehen Sie nichts.
Genau, wir machen das jetzt. Ich habe jetzt auch einen Ton ausgeschaltet, sodass der Vorführeffekt für die Podcast-Hörer noch besser wird. So, da ist er.
Hat er da eigentlich kaplimm gemacht.
Weil ich einen Ton aus hatte. Soll ich mal einen Ton anmachen? Ich mach noch mal einen Ton an.
Das ist auch egal, aber da kommt jetzt so wie bei einer SMS...
Im Walde sitzt ein Auerhahn, der schaut mich ganz schön sauer an.
Da kommt jetzt wie bei einer SMS, kommt jetzt halt von Beehive.
Da war's.
Von Bejive. Das macht relativ frei so plopp.
Also man kann verschiedene Sounds einstellen bei Bejive.
Das ist ein Kanzler. Warte mal, jetzt haben wir den Dialog. Und wenn du jetzt Anzeigen machst, dann geht er in das Programm.
Dann startet das Programm. Das ist auf einem 3G relativ langsam und das Programm konnektiert sich dann. Ganz schick, wenn man hier ein gejailbreaktes Phone hat und dann Status Notifications an, dann hat man da oben so ein kleines Smiley, das einem anzeigt, dass man eine neue Insta-Message hat.
Was ist das für ein AP?
Das ist Status Notifier, heißt das, glaube ich. Das ist ein, wenn man ein Jailbreak Phone hat, zeigt das einem an, wenn man hier einen Ton aus hat.
Hat das Programm explizit Support für Jailbreakte Sachen?
Ich nehme umgekehrt, dass die in die Datenbank reingucken. Aber es funktioniert in dem Moment, in dem du eine Nachricht hast, brauchst du nicht mal das Programm zu starten. Sobald du eine Notification bekommst, zack, ist wieder sichtbar. Also es funktioniert nicht immer. Es ist relativ schnell, diese Notifications. Das kriegt man, wenn man mal chattet. Dadurch, dass Bejive langsam ist, ist noch nicht der Weisert letzter Schluss. Also wenn man dann eine Nachricht bekommt, dann muss man halt warten, bis das Programm gestartet ist und so. Aber das geht eigentlich ganz gut. Worauf ich jetzt noch warte, ist ein vernünftiger Twitter-Client, der auch...
Also was man auf jeden Fall jetzt hier nochmal erwähnen müsste. Push für Jabba, da haben wir ja viel drüber geredet, geht bei diesen Diensten nur deshalb, weil man sein Passwort dort hinterlegt.
Genau, also die sind für mich ja auch online. Jetzt läuft ja das Programm nicht, aber ich werde trotzdem als online angezeigt.
Man ist jetzt einfach nicht mehr online, sondern man lässt online sein. Also das ist ja wirklich auch eine neue Stufe im Internet.
Außer dieses Aim von AOL, da machen die die Kommunikation direkt mit Apple. Da fällt der Middleman weg, weil die haben den Passwort, eh, da fällt er nicht auf.
Weil es halt der offizielle Client ist sozusagen.
Das heißt, da kommen eventuell dann demnächst die Jabber-Demons raus, die direkt mit Apple quatschen können und dann fällt das weg. Kann man ja mal von ausgehen.
Ja, das ist eben die Frage, ob es da wirklich Open-Source-Entwicklung, also ob ejabber.de das zum Beispiel einbaut. Ich hoffe.
Ich will nicht meine Passwörter bei mehreren Instanzen haben.
Nee, das will ich auch nicht. Das ist einfach mal doof. Gerade bei so was wie Chat. Ich meine, Vertrauen kann man dem ja, aber kann man halt auch nicht vertrauen.
Ich will es möglichst einschränken, wer überall meine Passwörter hat.
Ja, aber es ist eine Lösung, wenn man damit leben kann, dass da noch irgendein Hersteller von irgendeiner Software, die mein Passwort hat, meine Zugangsdaten und sich für mich einloggen kann, dann ist es wirklich eine gut funktionierende Lösung. Ich hab so beide gegeneinander laufen lassen und iM Plus kann zwar auch Twitter und all so ein Zeug, aber es sieht einfach total scheiße aus und es funktioniert auch nicht so gut wie BeeJive.
Ich sehe gerade im Chat gibt es einen Link, es gibt tatsächlich dieses Modul für iJobber, die bereits. Irgendwie, was ist das? 10 User, ein Jahr Subscription, 50 Euro.
Ja, da war halt der erste. Kommt demnächst noch einer und noch einer und noch einer bis nichts mehr kostet.
Ja, denke ich auch. Aber interessant, dass das schon so ein Markt ist, dass sie sich da drauf stürzen. Ach man. Interessante Bude.
Und habt ihr das Gefühl, dass mit der 3.0, dass euer iPhone schneller leer ist? Also zum Beispiel, du hast jetzt Push-Notification an, dazu musst du dein Telefon dauerhafte Connection zu Apple haben. Ja, viel schneller leer. Genau. Und hatte ich nämlich bei mir auch irgendwie das Gefühl. Und jetzt gibt es ja, wenn man Push-Notification hat, ich weiß nicht, wer es noch nicht gesehen hat, in den Einstellungen gibt es ja jetzt den Push-Notification-Button, jetzt gleich an vierter Stelle prominent irgendwie platziert.
Da wo vorher Push war, ne?
Und das sieht so ein bisschen aus wie das Auge von 2001. Das ist der Herrl-Computer.
Ist einfach roter Punkt.
Und ich hab's erstmal ausgeschaltet, weil ich hab ja keine Notifications und da ich aber jetzt immer ab und zu mal Flight-Control spiele und ganz losermäßig noch immer bei 60 rumhänge, kann ich jetzt nicht so einschätzen, wie lange meine Batterie hält.
Nee, also ist es auffällig, dass der Akku kürzer hält. Was ich ja schick finde...
So gesehen hat der Apple Recht.
Wie hat der Apple Recht?
Na, wenn Sie gleich jetzt schon am Anfang mit Push-Notifications oder mit sowas gekommen wären, dann wäre irgendwie, weiß nicht wie lange deine Batterie jetzt hält, aber nochmal radikal kürzer als es vorher schon gewesen wäre. Weil es ja auch so eine Art Background Process, halt nur einer, der sich jetzt zu Apple connectet.
Was ich ja ganz schick finden würde in Bezug auf dieses Speed-Drive, dass wenn man hier diese, dass die Programme, die einem Notifications schicken, auch darüber informiert werden würden, wenn man hier den Ringer auf offsetzt, dass die dann zum Beispiel die Möglichkeit hätten, in dem Fall jetzt zum Beispiel Bejive zu sagen, jetzt ist er aber auch wirklich mal offline, wenn ich den Ringer auf, also den Schalter auf laut losstelle. Wird fändlich noch total super, weil dann könnte man wirklich sagen, ich bin wirklich nicht ansprechbar. Weil ist ja eigentlich total blöd, dass wenn man...
Aber eigentlich muss man sich das mal wegdenken, dass es noch so ein Modus gibt wie offline und online.
Das heißt offline und online ist es halt...
Guck mal bei einem normalen Telefon, rechnen wir jetzt mal 20 Jahre zurück, da gab es ja auch nicht irgendwie, dass man sehen konnte, der Max schläft gerade oder er schläft nicht. Wenn ich einen erreichen wollte, hat er dich angerufen, der wurde ja auch nicht vorgewarnt.
Genau, und da sind wir auch glücklich, dass die Zeiten vorbei sind.
Ja, aber wozu willst du dann noch irgendjemanden mitteilen, du wärst nicht online? Dann stapeln sich die Nachrichten halt und holst sie halt später, aber ist doch egal.
Damit er mitkriegt, dass ich nicht online bin.
Das merkt er dann schon, wenn du nicht rangehst und nicht reagierst.
Na ja gut, also Presence ist auch ein Feature.
Presence ist ein Feature, was ich gerne haben möchte.
Wenn du das nicht haben willst, nimmst du halt Twitter.
Also ich würde es schon schick finden, wenn ich hier über diesen Schalter nicht nur regeln könnte, dass das den Gleis ist und dass ich jetzt gerade keine Anrufe haben möchte, sondern dass ich auch darüber feststellen kann, ja bitte quatsch mich auch per Inselmessage nicht an, weil ich bin gerade in einem Gespräch. Das ist mein kleiner Do Not Disturb-Button.
Hier schreibt mir gerade einer auf Twitter, bzw. schreibt uns einer auf Twitter, also dem MobileMax-Account. Dafür können wir auch mal kurz Werbung machen. Dass sie im Apple Store ein Kontaktproblem mit Druckluft gelöst hätten.
Mit Druckluft?
Ja, wieso nicht? Weil da so ein Krümel drin steckt oder irgendwie so.
Aber das glaube ich nicht. Na gut, glauben heißt nicht wissen. Wenn ich in München bin, dann werde ich da vielleicht mal hinfahren und mal gucken, ob sie mir mal auf Kulanz da mal so ein Rad geben. Aber da komme ich jetzt gerade erst mal nicht wieder vorbei. Ist ja mal alles nicht so einfach mit diesen weit entfernten Orten. Ich war, da war ich ja jetzt auch gerade erst vor zwei Wochen. Wisst ihr eigentlich, ob diese Mac Pros leise sind, die aktuellen?
Die großen?
Weil ich stehe ja wirklich auf Computer, die leise sind. Und wenn mich wirklich irgendwas an meinem MacBook nervt, dann ist es einfach dieser Lärm, den das Gerät erzeugen kann.
Die ganz, ganz großen?
Ja, die haben ja schon so einen.
Oh, es gibt ja nur einen.
Kommt drauf an, wie viel Festplatten da drin ist? Weil Festplatten an sich machen ja schon alle.
So, ob sie sozusagen im Wesentlichen, wenn sie so im Betrieb sind, nicht wie die Blöden durch die Gegend gasen.
Die gasen durch die Gegend, weil so wie ich dich gernasse, oder tausend Programme auf, die alle irgendwie zu tun haben, dann läuft die CPU halt mal warm und der Lüfter muss es wegtransportieren. Also für deinen Fall würde ich mal hier ein Ja ankreuzen.
Ja sind laut meinst du?
Ja, klar, wenn du da auch den benutzt hast, machen die natürlich Lärm. Wenn du den nicht benutzt, glaube ich, sind die relativ leise.
Das müssen wir mal sehen.
Nun ja, kleiner Nachtrag zum Thema Tethering. Du hast im letzten Mal irgendwas erzählt, dass es mit GPS nicht geht oder so. Ich war jetzt am Wochenende im Brandenburgischen, absolut problemlos.
Ja, da bin ich jetzt auch schon mehrfach drauf hingewiesen worden und offensichtlich war das von mir einfach eine Fehlwahrnehmung. Ich hatte halt den Eindruck, dass eben mein Tethering aus war, wenn eben kein OMTS mehr verfügbar war. Irgendwie war das während dieser Bahnfahrt, naja, hat sich mir das eben einfach so dargestellt. Ich hab dann später bemerkt, dass eben dieses iPhone, unter Gründen, die ich auch noch nicht ganz ergründet habe, dieses Tethering einfach ausschaltet manchmal. Also ich hab einfach mein Telefon, immer mal wieder muss ich diese Option explizit einschalten.
Ach, komplett abschalten, also in den Einstellungen abschalten oder was?
Jaja, ich geh in das Setting und der sagt, Tethering ist aus.
Ach, das sag ich überhaupt nicht, das Problem.
Keine Ahnung, wodurch das kommt, aber das ist mir halt ein paar Mal passiert und deswegen eben auch diese Vermutung, dass es eben da, dass er nicht liefert, obwohl ich es eingeschaltet habe, aber es war halt nur so, er hat halt das Setting ausgeschaltet. Ich hab aber keine Ahnung, warum, wieso, naja.
Ich war übrigens, wollte ich das als kleine elegant Überleitung machen auf das nächste Thema.
Eine vertrauenswürdige Quelle meint gerade, dass der Mac Pro relativ leise sei und ich sollte keine Sorgen haben.
Doch mal schön.
Sorge dich nicht.
Und was macht der damit?
Wer?
Deine vertrauenswürdige Quelle.
Die vertrauenswürdige Quelle nutzt bestimmt mehr CPU-Cycles als ich das vorhabe.
Ist der VJ?
Nee, aber da ist definitiv Vio am Start.
Verstehe.
Vielen Dank, vertrauenswürdige Quelle.
Geheimnisvolle vertrauenswürdige Quelle, falls ich das ergänzen darf.
Aber ich habe noch was anderes erforscht. Oder wolltest du gerade beim Thema bleiben?
Ich wollte jetzt gerade zu meinem großen, warum ich in Brandenburg, was ich in Brandenburg noch gemacht habe, auf dem Weg dahin.
Du hast Stimmen für die Piratenpartei gesammelt.
Achso, nee, das nicht.
Nein?
Nee, Navigationssysteme getestet.
Ah, da-da-da. Okay.
Ich hab ja ganz furchtbar gemackert über Navigon.
Ja.
In erster Linie wegen dem Preis. 100 Euro finde ich nach wie vor ziemlich unverschämt.
Den Preis kann man nie meckern. Entweder man kauft's oder man kauft's nicht und dann...
Ich finde, man kann sehr wohl über den Preis meckern. Und als Alternative dazu hab ich jetzt noch... Also auf der Hinfahrt hab ich mit Navigon gemacht zum Badesee und auf den Rückweg bin ich mit Roadie gefahren. Das ist ein kleines Navigationssystem für 1,79 aus dem App Store.
Mit OpenStreetMap.
Was mit OpenStreetMap fährt.
Was erstaunlich ist, weil ich hab ja einen Podcast gemacht zur OpenStreetMap und da war ja noch die Einschätzung, das ist ja jetzt gar nicht so lange her, da war noch die Einschätzung, dass eigentlich das Datenmaterial so für Routing noch gar nicht so gedacht ist.
Ich glaube, die nutzen auch, der nutzt für das, also um die Strecke berechnen zu lassen, nutzt der auch nicht OpenStreetMap, sondern irgendeinen anderen Dienst, der aber auch freie Daten zurückliefert. Den kann ich mal, der stand irgendwo mit Einstellungen drin. Und angezeigt wird das Ganze dann mit den OpenStreetMaps. Aber fangen wir mal an mit Navigon. Also erstens, wo es großartig ist, ist auf der Autobahn. Also wir sind ein bisschen aus Berlin rausgefahren und so ein bisschen die Autobahn lang und dann irgendwo an einen kleinen See runtergefahren. Und auf der Autobahn fährst du da lang und siehst immer vorne die Straße sozusagen. Und wenn du in der Nähe einer Abfahrt kommst, dann zeigt er dir an, auf welcher Spur du jetzt sein musst. Also er zeigt dir an, die Autobahn hat drei Spuren und zwei Abbiegespuren, z.B. weil es an einem Autobahnkreuz ist und dann zeigt er dir haargenau an, auf welche du jetzt drauf musst und auf welche davon in Frage kommst. Er zeigt dir oben sowieso diese blauen Autobahnschilder an, in welche Richtung du jetzt musst. Also jetzt z.B. fahr jetzt in Richtung Dresden weiter.
Last Exit Brooklyn.
Das ist echt ganz, ganz großartig. Wo es bei mir komplett versagt hat, war im Stadtverkehr. Also es ist, die Ansagen kommen oft viel, viel zu spät. Also statt, biegen sie jetzt rechts ab, müsstest du eigentlich sagen, sie hätten jetzt rechts abbiegen müssen, weil teilweise wirklich erst auf der Kreuzung kommt die Ansage, dass du jetzt abbiegen musst. Also wenn du dich blind auf die Ansagen verlässt, hast du echt ein Problem.
Er sagt auch nicht sowas wie in 200 Metern rechts abbiegen?
Auf der Autobahn macht er das alles super, aber in der Stadt sind das teilweise einfach keine 200 Meter. Wenn du da abbiegst und dann musst du ja sofort wieder abbiegen, dann musst du sozusagen aufs Display gucken.
TomTom sagt dann immer sowas wie biegen sie rechts ab, dann biegen sie links ab.
Nee, sowas macht er nicht. Und was mir extrem negativ aufgefallen ist, was auf der Autobahn auch überhaupt kein Problem war, der GPS-Empfang. Also auf der Autobahn hat man einfach GPS-Empfang und alles ist super. In der Stadt hat man ständig GPS-Abrüche. Und dann verzerrt sich oben diese Statusleiste rot. Und da steht dann GPS. Und das Verhalten des Apps in dem Moment ist selten dämlich. Nämlich, er glaubt einfach, man würde stehen bleiben. Also wenn man mit 120 auf der Stadtautobahn fährt und er kriegt plötzlich kein GPS-Signal mehr, stellt er alle weiteren Dienste erstmal ein. Und bleibt an der Stelle, an der du gerade bist. Also als ob das Programm eingefroren wäre. Und dass man natürlich gerade auf einer Stadtautobahn in der Zeit durchaus an der Obfahrt vorbeigefahren sein könnte, an der man eigentlich runter musste, kann man in dem Moment gar nicht mehr feststellen. Weil man sieht es auch nicht. Also das ist wirklich so, wo ich sagen muss, und da muss ich sagen, für eine 100 Euro App, also für eine 10 Euro App, könnte man das vielleicht durchgehen lassen, so nach dem Motto, für 20 Euro, ja, ist die erste Version.
Aber ist jetzt keine 100 Euro bezahlt, sondern nur 50 oder so, oder? Das war doch jetzt erstmal ein bisschen billiger am Angang.
Na ich hab eine Trial-Version sozusagen, die ich jetzt auch wieder löschen werde.
Trial-Version?
Trial-Version immer aus einem Interwebbrunter geladen.
So eine Hacke die Hacke, naja. Na ja, vielleicht hat es deshalb nicht so gut funktioniert.
Ich hab die gleichen Geschwerden auch von Leuten gehört, die sich das Programm gefasst haben.
Also ich war ja letztes Wochenende in Bamberg.
Achso, ganz kurz? Was noch war, der Akku stirbt mit dem Ding unglaublich schnell. Also es ist im Auto, das war das Auto meiner Freundin, die hat so ein Autoradio mit einem USB-Anschluss, da kann ich immer das iPhone anschließen, damit es lädt. Es hat, obwohl es an ein Ladegerät steckte, wurde der Akku noch leer auf der Hinfahrt.
Zieht mehr Saft, als er laden kann.
Es zieht mehr Saft, als der USB-Anschluss liefert. Nun weiß ich nicht, ob das ein vollwertiger USB-Anschluss da ist.
Es ist wahrscheinlich nur ein normaler 0,5 Ampere, nicht eben ein Ampere, was das Ladegerät liefert.
Zwischendurch auf der Rückfahrt sah es dann besser aus, da hat sich dann einfach der Prozentsatz gar nicht geändert. Aber auf der Hinfahrt war wirklich, wenn der GPS-Empfang, oder ich weiß nicht nach welchem Prinzip das ist, schlecht genug ist, dann saubert es einem wirklich den Akku leer.
Den Effekt habe ich aber auch schon mal, wenn man einen am Rechner hat, am normalen USB-Port, und du machst irgendwie Tethering und du nutzt das Teil noch so, dann wird der irgendwie auch nicht voll. Und auch eher noch leerer, wenn er voll war.
Das kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, aber das ist so, wenn man gerade, also ich meine mit einem Navigationssystem will man ja eher so mal 3-4 Stunden am Stück fahren. Ich würde mal behaupten, in vielen Situationen hält das der Akku einfach nicht durch.
Ja, also ich muss sagen, Navigationssysteme auf dem iPhone, okay, mein ich wegen, ich hätte aber lieber was für Fahrrad- und Fußgängerbetrieb als für Auto. Auto kann man nun wirklich echt sich einen Autoteil reinbauen.
Kann man umschalten auf Fahrrad- oder Fußgängermodus. Auf dem Fahrrad hab ich es auch ausprobiert mit dem Navigon. Da schlagen die Probleme noch gleich mal viel schlimmer rein. Also während man ja das zu späte Ansagen der Kreuzung, wenn du mit dem Auto fährst, hast du ja wenigstens das Display vor dir und kannst sehen, was sich gerade abspielt, also wo man abbiegen muss. Wenn du dagegen auf dem Fahrrad sitzt, hast du das iPhone in der Tasche. Und es passiert und du kriegst es nicht mit. Und wenn er dann eben den GPS-Punkt verliert, Kontakt, was er in der Stadt, wie gesagt, ständig tut. Also ich bin über die Oberbaumbrücke gefahren und bin zwei Kilometer lang gefahren. Und er hat in den zwei Kilometern, also ungefähr zwei Kilometern, immer noch gedacht, ich wäre auf der Oberbaumbrücke. Also wirklich hätte ich nicht gewusst, wo ich hin wollte, wäre ich niemals da angekommen. Und das finde ich nämlich auch ein bisschen, weil während ich ja von diesen Google-Karten da drin wirklich gewohnt bin, dass die mich, du wirst wahrscheinlich von deinem auch kennen, wenn du in einer Stadt unterwegs bist, nicht irgendwo lokalisieren lässt, auch komplett ohne GPS, das geht einfach bis auf 10, 15 Meter genau.
30 sind oder 15.
Ja, aber auf jeden Fall close enough. Und dass diese Information nicht mitgenutzt wird von dem Navigationssystem, finde ich dann doch irgendwie sehr, sehr schade. Also die verlassen sich offensichtlich wirklich nur aufs GPS.
Da wird es doch aber eigentlich. Die nutzen auch die Apple API und die Apple API ist diese Location und der holt irgendwie alles, was er kriegen kann als Information.
Nein, macht er definitiv.
Verlangen keine GPS.
Nein, macht er nicht, macht er nicht. Also das Programm macht das nicht. Was macht das Programm nicht? Es nutzt wirklich nur GPS-Information. Also wenn ich jetzt hier sagen würde, rechne mir mal von hier im geschlossenen Gebäude eine Strecke aus, würde ich einfach sagen, ich habe kein GPS-Signal, kann ich nicht.
Naja, du kannst ja Mutmaßungen machen, ob das, was dir die Location liefert, jetzt vom GPS kommt oder aus anderen Daten, ist eine Abhängigkeit davon, wie groß der Umkreis ist.
Ich nehme an, dass Call Location auch mitteilen wird, woher die Daten jetzt kommen.
Nee, ich glaube, das tut es gar nicht.
Das sagt halt nur die Fehlerrate, an welchem Umkreis du bist.
Genau.
Also die Position mit welchem Radius, wo du dich drin befindest.
Aber was ist denn, wenn die Maps-Applikation auf dem iPhone blinkt, was heißt denn das? Heißt das nicht, dass er dann...
Wenn er blinkt, dann hat er einen GPS-Fix.
Das glaube ich nämlich auch.
Bei mir blinkt nichts.
Ja genau, das ist nämlich so. Also wenn du halt wirklich einen Fix hast, dann blinkt dieser Punkt.
Genau, also krieg die Maps-Applikation mitgeteilt, auf jeden Fall, ob sie einen GPS-Fix hat oder nicht.
Okay, wir wissen es nicht so genau und reden trotzdem darüberbereich, das ist immer sehr kritisches Wasser. Das lassen wir doch mal.
Also ich würde aber trotzdem behaupten, das ist ein Programmfehler. Egal, was ich jetzt noch erzählen wollte, ich war halt in Bamberg und war auch irgendwie ohne TomTom, sondern nur mit dem iPhone und wir mussten halt zu einer gewissen Adresse. Ich war mit einem Freund unterwegs, mit Motorrad und mein Kumpel hat halt ein 3G, also mit GPS. Noch nicht das neue, sondern normal. Und kein Navigationsprogramm und wir wollten aber trotzdem irgendwie die Adresse finden. Also einfach das Ding unter den Tankrucksack legen, das ist auch so eine Klarsichtfolie, weiß schon, wo man eigentlich seine Karten hinlegt. Und dann haben wir ein Fähnchen oder so ein Pin da gemacht, wo wir hinwollen und halt der blaue Punkt, da wo wir gerade sind und ich hab einfach mal geguckt, so dass ich mich nähere und ich finde, weil ich hab auch ein TomTom und ich finde, so konnte ich eigentlich auch prima irgendwie das Ziel so. Du fährst einfach ungefähr so in die Richtung. Ist vielleicht ein bisschen schwierig bei Einbahnstraßen, aber so grundsätzlich finde ich, das ist nicht schlimm, wenn du mal irgendwie eine Straße zu spät abbiegst oder so, weil du weißt, du musst in die Richtung. Ne, ich mein jetzt richtige Karten, so Straßenkarten. Wie willst du das machen? Dann musst du dann so richtig genau drauf gucken. Wir haben das einfach so gemacht und das hat, ich fand das hat super gut funktioniert.
Hast du das aber jetzt nicht verstanden?
Also ich geb ein, wo ich hin will, dann kommt ja so ein roter Pin. Und dann ist ja automatisch auch noch der blaue Punkt dort, wo halt das GPS sagt, wo ich gerade bin. Und die Karte, da hab ich also schon zwei Punkte. Und dann bin ich einfach so gefahren, dass ich in Richtung Ziel fahre. Also zu dem roten Punkt. Und das geht super gut.
Und warum hast du nicht einfach die...
Und warum lässt es ja nicht eine Route geben?
Weil ich nicht nach Route fahren wollte. Das nervt auch immer zu gucken. Ich hab gedacht, wir fahren ungefähr in die Richtung. Wenn ich ein bisschen genauer dran bin, halt ich kurz an. Zoom Stück rein und hab es genauer. Das ging verdammt gut. Also nicht weil ich hab einen Tomcam und kenn eigentlich den Luxus von...
Okay, ich hab's anders verstanden. Ich dachte, das wär jetzt das Problem, dass kein Kartenmaterial vorhanden ist. Da gibt's ja, hab ich schon mal erwähnt, dieses Open-Street-Map, Off-Maps. Hab ich schon mal erwähnt. Ich erwähne es gerne nochmal. Off-Maps ist halt so wie das Maps, also weitgehend so ähnlich, bloß nutzt er halt auch Open-Street-Map-Karten und hat eben die Möglichkeit, auch Karten vorher downzuloaden. Das heißt, du kannst halt einfach so einen Kartenbereich markieren mit dem Finger und dann eben den Level angeben, dann sagt er dir, wie viele Megabyte das so wären. Und dann lädt er einfach diesen Block runter und wenn du dann halt irgendwo bist und ein bisschen abhamba und hast kein Internet, kannst du die Appliquale starten und hast eine volle Kartenauflösung mit OpenStreetMap-Detail-Level. Mit diesen Cloud-Made-Karten. Das ist eigentlich ein sehr schönes Ding.
Genau, da kann ich ja jetzt gleich mal entschließen, das ist nämlich dieses Roadie, das ich dann auf der Rückfahrt getestet habe. Das macht im Wesentlichen ist das genau das, was du haben wolltest, Dennis. Das zeigt ja OpenStreetMaps an, wo befinde ich mich gerade, zeigt dir eine Route an und packt quasi die Karte unten drunter, dass die immer so genordet ist.
Das mit dem Norden hatte ich nicht, sondern ich musste halt so im Kopf mir das hin drehen. Aber ich fand das, ich fühlte mich freier irgendwie. Man macht keine Fehler mehr, weil TomTom sagt, du musst dich abbiegen. Dann ist da eine Bauschei und denkst, oh Gott, jetzt muss ich irgendwie rumfahren und so. Und du machst mehr Fehler, weil du irgendwo abbiegen willst. Also weil dir der TomTom sagt, du musst abbiegen, da darfst du dann aber eigentlich gar nicht. Also ich glaube, die Fehlerrate ist höher, wenn du dich so auf dein Navi verlässt. Wenn ich aber einfach nur so in eine Richtung so, ich muss ungefähr da lang, dann gucke ich viel mehr selbst, wo ich langfahren kann, man ist viel mehr mit dabei.
Ja, dieses ganze Navigieren, das ist auch da, manchmal macht man sich damit echt auch wahnsinnig. Ich bin ja zum Beispiel, ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, es gibt ja Leute, die können das gar nicht, aber ich habe so irgendwie einen Sinn für Navigation. Also ich verliere sehr selten die Orientierung. Ich kann einfach auch an Orten, die maximal irgendwie in der Pampa sind oder halt in fremden Städten, ich da irgendwie mal irgendwo lang gelaufen bin, ich fände immer meinen Weg wieder, ich weiß eigentlich immer in etwa, wo was ist und so, ich verliere einfach weder die räumliche, also weder die Verbindung zu dem Weg, den ich gegangen bin, noch verliere ich meine direkte geografische Orientierung. Das heißt, ich kann immer noch sagen, in welche Richtung ich gehen müsste, um wieder zurückzukommen. Und da hat es mir immer sehr geholfen, dass ich eigentlich nur mit Karten gearbeitet habe, um mir das eben auch gleich so einzuprägen und diese Navigationssysteme, die einem immer sagen, ich kann dir jederzeit sagen, wo du bist, ich kann dir jederzeit sagen, wo du hingehst, die trainieren halt deinen Hirn nicht. Das ist ein echtes Problem und deswegen werde ich auch irgendwann da wieder Abstand von nehmen, um das eben nicht zu verlieren, weil wenn man das nicht regelmäßig trainiert, dann wird das Hirn echt blöd. Leute, die das eh nicht können, die ist natürlich geholfen.
Ich finde es auf der Autobahn eigentlich ganz angenehm, so ein Navi, weil man so komplett vor sich, du kannst Auto fahren und kannst eigentlich nebenbei was anderes machen.
Ja, das ist auch kein Navigieren, das ist ja nur so, wann muss ich rechts abbiegen?
Das ist im Wesentlichen als ob ein Wecker klingeln würde, der dir rechtzeitig Bescheid sagt, jetzt ist deine Autobahnausfahrt da.
Das ist ja auch nicht mehr ganz so logisch wie in der Stadt, weil da musst du auf der Autobahn grundsätzlich immer rechts abbiegen, obwohl in Wirklichkeit du jetzt dann die Straße links von der Autobahn vorgesehen hast.
Dafür ist es aber auch super ausgeschildert.
Ja klar, aber da geht es halt nicht, dass du so nach Richtung fährst, wie ich gerade so gemeint sage.
Aber in der Stadt fand ich das auch, also gerade auch bei dieser Navigon-Software jetzt mal, du siehst im Wesentlichen die nächste Kreuzung. Und wenn dich das System in den 200 Metern, die du jetzt hast, verlässt, weil du eben zum Beispiel keine GPS-Position hast, weil, und das ist, finde ich, bei beiden extrem nervig, bei beiden Programmen, du hast keine iPod-Steuerung in den Dingern drin. Das heißt, wenn du das Ding angeschlossen hast an die Anlage vom Auto, hörst nebenbei Musik, wenn du jetzt auf die Idee kommst...
Wo hast du keine iPod-Steuerung?
In den Navigationsprogrammen auf dem iPhone. Du kannst nicht die iPod-Musik darüber steuern, über Navigon zum Beispiel. Das heißt, wenn du zwischendurch, also wenn du hörst Musik, willst andere Musik hören, das heißt, das Programm verlassen, iPod starten, Musik wechseln, zurück in Navigon, und die Navigon ist auf...
Na gut, du hast ja so eine Fernbedienung.
Nein, du kannst vorwärts und zurück, könntest du über so eine Fernbedienung machen, aber dass du jetzt ein komplett anderes Album oder sowas auswählst, geht leider nicht.
Ach so, na gut, aber das haben sie halt in die Software noch nicht eingebaut.
Das haben sie natürlich jetzt auch. Genau, das ginge nämlich, und der große Nachteil daran ist nämlich, dass das Programm unendlich lange braucht, um zu starten. Ich glaube sowas, also ich hab letztlich nicht genau gestoppt, aber so im anderthalb, zwei Minuten Bereich auf dem 3G. Und das ist lang. Und ich hab's wirklich geschafft, dadurch eine Ausfahrt zu verpassen. Und das ist echt, das ist echt nervig. Es ist, muss man allerdings auch sagen, das Navigon setzt danach, also während hier Rody danach dich treu blöd wieder fragst, ah, wo willst du denn hinfahren? Weißt das Navigon immerhin noch, dass du unterwegs warst und wo du hin wolltest und fängt an, dir quasi deine neue Position wieder zu berechnen, was dann auch nochmal noch ein bisschen dauert. Und dir dann aber schön wenigstens zu sagen, dass du jetzt bei nächster Gelegenheit doch bitte wenden sollst. Aber das ist irgendwie, also schneller starten muss das Programm auf jeden Fall noch. Und ich finde, dass eine iPod-Steuerung, wenn sie vom System geliefert wird, bei so einem Programm so wichtig ist wie bei kaum einem anderen Programm. Dass das geht, dass man ohne das Programm zu verlassen zumindest so eine Minimalfunktion nutzen kann.
Sehe ich eh nicht.
Noch mal zu Roadie, noch mal so zwei, drei Worte. Also das Navigon ist dramatisch überlegen natürlich. Also das ist bei Roadie sieht man, also man hat eine Karte und man muss sich im Wesentlichen selber orientieren, gerade auf der Autobahn. Also da hast du nämlich plötzlich diese Problematik mit dem, dass der nach rechts runter muss, auch wenn du nach links abbiegen willst und sowas. Das zeigt dir das ganze System natürlich überhaupt nicht an. Das ist, wenn man zwischendurch mal keinen Empfang hat, dann fährt man mit Roadie einfach auf der grauen Fläche. Wenn man neben der Straße herfährt und das System glaubt Roadie gern mal so, ah ich glaube jetzt ist er mal von der Autobahn runtergesprungen auf die Landstraße, die daneben ist, weil die GPS-Daten nicht 100%ig stimmen, fängt an eine komplett neue Route zu berechnen im Hintergrund. Also da muss das Programm definitiv robuster werden und man hat überhaupt keine Ansage. Aber ich finde für meine Bedürfnisse, also eher als Wanderer, also eher zu Fuß oder mit dem Rad unterwegs und eigentlich nie mit dem Auto, für den es sich wirklich nicht lohnt, 100 Euro für ein Navigationssystem auszugeben, kann man definitiv mal die 2 Euro für die Software springen lassen, insbesondere weil die Ansagen auch mit der nächsten Version kommen sollen. Aber ja, ich bin mal sehr auf Sumtum gespannt.
Ja, jetzt haben wir aber auch alles gesagt zu dem Thema, oder?
Ich glaube schon. Ja, aber ich bin extra Baden gefahren.
Ich habe auch mir mal was angeguckt und zwar habe ich mal diesen Ding hinterher geforscht mit der Abspielgeschwindigkeit auf dem iPhone und auf dem Mac. Dieses ominöse halbe Geschwindigkeit, doppelte Geschwindigkeit. Das gibt es ja im iPhone, eben genau in diesen Stufen. Das heißt, entweder hast du normal oder du hast also entweder 1x, 2x oder 0,5x. Das sind ja die, also wenn im Podcast...
Wie wir gerade nicht 1,2 machen? Das ist ja doof. Weil doppelt schon ganz schön krass, oder?
Ja, doppelt wäre ganz schön krass. Es zeigt sich bloß, dass es sich hierbei überhaupt nicht umdoppelt handelt. Sondern die nennen das zwar so, aber tatsächlich ist es anders. Und ich hab jetzt... Ich hätte jetzt ganz gerne noch ein bisschen mehr Zeit gehabt, dem genauer nachzugehen, aber es ist erst mal so. Wenn du auf dem iPhone einen Podcast abspielst, ich hab das jetzt getestet mit Audio und ich vermute mal... Ach nee, bei Video geht das ja gar nicht. Also, dann bedeutet 0,5, dass du einen... Dass es 0,8 mal so schnell spielt. Also, was vorher 120 Sekunden sind, dauert 150 Sekunden und nicht etwa 60 Sekunden.
Nee, Moment mal.
Du hast zwei Minuten Audio. Eine Datei, die zwei Minuten ist. Und du stellst dein iPhone auf 0,5 Abspielgeschwindigkeit.
Müsste dann eigentlich 60 Sekunden sein, die Hälfte ist aber nicht so.
Man würde jetzt erwarten, dass das bedeutet, dass es dann 60 Sekunden lang läuft.
Bei halber Geschwindigkeit würde ich erwarten, dass es doppelt so lange läuft.
Ähm, richtig. Das ist 200, Entschuldigung. Also 120 Sekunden, man würde erwarten, dass es 240 Sekunden lang läuft. So, jetzt erstmal auf erste Erwartungshaltung. Dem ist nicht so, sondern es läuft 150 Sekunden.
Also mit 0,8-facher Geschwindigkeit.
Quasi.
Genau, es dauert ein Viertel länger. Sagen wir es mal so.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall deutlich schneller noch als halbe Geschwindigkeit.
Warum machen die das so?
Gute Frage. So, dann hab ich mir die doppelte, also das zweifach angeschaut. 120 Sekunden spielen in 80 Sekunden weg. Das heißt, hier hast du tatsächlich eineinhalb.
Wahrscheinlich weil die Amis alle keine Bruchrechnung können. Darum schauen wir so zweifach auf eineinhalb hin.
Völlig komisch, ne? Dann hab ich es mal verglichen wie das auf dem Mac ist mit QuickTime. Du kannst ja im QuickTime Player mit Uplk, also in diesem Pro-Modus, da kann man ja sliden wie man will. Da kann man sliden wie man will, aber es gibt halt auch so Rasten. Es gibt auch da ein Halb.
Und da stimmt es dann aber auch, oder?
Naja, pass auf. Da gibt es ein Halb, dann gibt es 0, dann gibt es dazwischen noch einen. Du kannst da beliebig drinnen und her sliden. Dann gibt es 1 und 2 und 3 und auch immer dazwischen noch so einen kleinen Ticker. Und das muss ich jetzt hier nochmal ein bisschen gegentesten, aber die Ergebnisse waren überraschend. Und zwar erstens, wieder jetzt mal ausgehend, ich habe hier unterschiedliche Längen gemessen, das war alles so ein bisschen noch, wo ich noch am Testen war. Also erstmal, die 0,5 in QuickTime sind auch 0,5. Das heißt, da spielt etwas doppelt so lang. Eine Minute spielt zwei Minuten lang.
Also da stimmt's.
Auf 0,5, genau.
Und bei zwei auch doppelt so schnell. Also auf zwei Minuten wird eine Minute.
Warte mal, langsam, langsam, langsam. So, dann hab ich diesen, ähm, nicht durcheinander kommen. Dann hab ich den zwischen 0,5 und 0 genommen.
Zwischen 0,5 und 0?
Du hast da ein Playback Speed.
Die haben jetzt auf halbe Geschwindigkeit alle geschaltet.
So, und der hat irgendwie so eine Linie mit vier großen Rasten. Bei dem ersten steht 1,5, dann steht da mal 1, mal 2, mal 3.
Und dann hast du auch noch diese Zwischen-Dinger.
Da zwischen hast du noch die Zwischen-Dinger. So, wenn ich das Ding halt ganz nach links schiebe, auf 1,5x.
Das ist so ein Schieberegler, nicht so buttons-wie-bei-vor.
Dann ist das auch tatsächlich halb so langsam. Oder anders ausgedrückt, es spielt doppelt so lang. Ja. Wenn ich den zwischen mal eins und mal zwei und einhalb schiebe, was jetzt die Frage ist, wie man das nennt.
0,75.
Ja, so habe ich es ja auch genannt. Dann ist das auch 0,75.
Dann nennen wir es mal 0,75, oder?
Also, du willst damit sagen, dass auf dem Rechner da stimmen die Verhältnisse.
Also, den Faktor, den ich jetzt nenne, ist sozusagen, um wie viel es schneller wird. So, bei 0,5 wird es 0,5 schneller. Also langsamer. Bei 0,75 wird es halt auch 0,75.
Ich glaube, das haben jetzt alle verstanden.
So, mal eins ist halt mal eins. So, dann bin ich auf 1,5 gegangen. Also zwischen dem 1x und dem 2x. So, was würde man da warten, was es ist? Ja, würde man. Ist es aber nicht. Sondern es ist 1,25. Dann bin ich aufs Doppelte gegangen. Ja, und das ist 1,5. Das heißt, mal zwei ist 1,5. Genauso wie auf dem iPhone übrigens. Ja, also auf dem iPhone ist mal zwei. Das mal zwei ist auf dem iPhone und auf dem Mac identisch. Das 0,5 ist auf dem Mac und auf dem iPhone nicht identisch. Auf dem Mac ist es so, wie man es erwarten würde. Und auf dem iPhone ist es anders. Und das mal zwei ist sowohl auf dem Mac als auch auf dem iPhone anders. Und jetzt kommt es noch bekloppter. Wenn ich auf 2,5, also zwischen mal zwei und mal drei gehe, dann habe ich gemessen, ist es mal die Geschwindigkeit mal 1,75. Also er geht immer nur um 0,25 Schritte weiter. Und wenn ich auf mal drei mache, was würde man jetzt erwarten, dass er dann mal zwei macht, richtig? Nein, bei dreimal ist es wirklich mal drei. Das heißt in diesem allerletzten Bereich schießt es auf einmal extrem hoch und nur da ist es wirklich mal drei. Das ist völlig bekloppt und ja, völlig unklar. Was sie damit überhaupt bezwecken wollen, ist mir ein Rätsel. Sie schaffen da ein User-Interface.
Die wollen einfach nur, dass man damit so ein bisschen die Geschwindigkeit drehen kann. Weil meistens macht man das ja nicht nach den Zahlen, sondern vom Gefühl her, wie man da noch so mithalten kann, oder? Also das kommt ja auch auf den Sprechern. Bei so einem Pavel machst du drei und bei irgendwie so einem...
Ja, bei Pavel dachte ich halt immer, den kann ich zweieinhalb Mal so schnell hören. Stimmt aber gar nicht. Den könnte ich halt tatsächlich nur 1,75 Mal so schnell hören. Also das ist gar nicht so viel schneller. Wobei ich jetzt extrem Respekt bekommen habe vor Blinden, die mir irgendwie erzählt haben, sie könnten halt Audio in sechsfacher Geschwindigkeit hören. Und ich dachte schon, ich würde ja zumindest bis Faktor 2, 2,5 kommen. Aber nicht auch nur im geringsten. Also doppelt so schnell kann ich nicht.
Das ist die Bursache.
Wahrscheinlich.
Klar.
Vielleicht sollte ich einfach mal mit verbundenen Augen hier rumlaufen, weil ich auch besser höre.
So genug hier Podcasts, Beats. Die Leute langweilen sich, glaube ich, schon alle. Meinst du? Aufwachen alle. Klar, ist jetzt nicht so weltbewegend. Ich meine...
Nicht?
Nee, die meisten nutzen das Feature nicht mehr. Und die, die es benutzen, sind, glaube ich, zufrieden, dass sie es schneller machen können.
Dass du dich da mal nicht vertust, mein Freund.
Ich habe mich total unterhalten gefühlt dadurch, weil ich nur etwas anderes gemacht habe.
Eigentlich ist es dir doch auch egal, wie viel mal schnell es jetzt ist, weil du willst doch eigentlich nur rausfinden, wie viel du verträgst, wie viel es am Ende ist. Das ist doch eigentlich wurscht.
Ja, ich hätte es trotzdem auf dem iPhone gerne mal in Smooth. Bei mir ist dieses Mal zwei, was kein Mal zwei ist, ist mir trotzdem noch zu viel. Also 50 Prozent mehr Geschwindigkeit trifft es bei mir nicht.
Ja, das kann sein, dass sie da noch einen Fehler haben.
25 Prozent mehr. Also 25 Prozent schneller. Das hätte ich gern. Bitte einmal dann. Schickt es mir am besten gleich hier nach Hause. Bitte Steve. Steve ist ja wieder da jetzt.
Steve ist wieder da, stimmt ja.
Scene on Campus, sagt man.
Was ich jetzt gemacht habe, während du von unwichtigen Zeug geredet hast. Ich wollte nicht sagen, dass es unwichtig ist. Ich habe einfach nicht zugehört.
Ich gehe einfach.
Ist ein Programm namens Prol fürs iPhone, mit dem man sich...
Für Systemadministration Prols, die sich auch noch den letzten Syslog-Status auf ihrem Telefon anzeigen.
Mit dem man sich Groll-Notifications als Push-Notifications aufs iPhone schicken lassen kann.
Als Service.
Das heißt, man muss denen dann Syslog-Dateien schicken und dann...
Du musst denen deine Groll-Notifications schicken?
Ja, ins Internet hinein.
Ins Internet hinein? Das macht natürlich... Aber es ist ganz spannend für, dass man damit unter Umständen auch mal so ein paar neue Anwendungen machen kann.
Das ist wirklich cool. Das heißt, man könnte so auf seinem Rechner irgendwas...
Jobs starten.
Du lässt dir den ERC laufen oder den Download oder den... Und du kriegst immer eine Notification, wenn du eine neue Mail hast.
Das ist schon okay.
Kostet irgendwie 2,39 oder so was?
Na funktioniert das?
Hab ich, ich hab das gerade drunter geladen. Solange hast du wieder auch nicht gelabert. Und ich würde es ja noch besonders schick finden, wenn es noch eine Möglichkeit gäbe, das Ding zu hacken, damit man da auch Twitter-Notifications reinschmeißen kann.
Oh, es gibt hier iTwitter auch.
Ja, iTwitter hat eine ganz doofe Einschränkung.
Welche denn?
iTwitter ist ein Twitter-Client, der auch Push-Notifications kann. Und jetzt kommt die Einschränkung, die es absolut sinnlos macht, von anderen iTwitter-Usern.
Was?
Also man kriegt nur eine Push-Notification, wenn die andere Person ihre Tweets auch in iTwitter absetzt.
Oder?
Genau das, wovon wir immer geträumt haben.
Sehr sinnvoll. Okay, aber Proll irgendwie könnte tatsächlich... Könnte wirklich interessant sein.
Ja, oder?
Ja, ich überlege gerade wofür eigentlich.
Wie bei so vielen Dingen, oder?
Naja, ich meine, man könnte sozusagen alles, was der Rechner in irgendeiner Form per Growl signalisieren kann, könnte man dann in Echtzeit auf sein Telefon bekommen.
Genau.
Und das ist... Also bisher war mir das immer egal. Für manche Sachen der Growl, weil ich ja dann eh nicht davor sitze. Was weiß ich, deine Platte ist voll oder so.
Naja, Downloads sind unter Umständen ganz spannend. Wenn du gerne... Wenn dein Rechner offen bleibt.
Wenn du weißt, wenn du vom See zurückfahren musst.
Weil du jetzt die neue Linux-Distribution... Ich kann jetzt ja noch am See sitzen bleiben. Genau. Oder willst du das Haus verlassen währenddessen?
Genau. Und dann weißt du so, wenn ich jetzt nach Hause fahre, dann kann ich mich schön abends auf meinen Sofa setzen und mir den ganzen Abend auf einem Großbild bleiben, wenn meine Linux-Distribution anschauen.
Naja, oder einfach für den ganz simplen Fall, wenn ich Adium offen habe und bin jetzt gerade beim Essen kochen, was ist das, also Pizza in den Ofen schieben, mit anderen Worten, dann werde ich informiert darüber, falls ich in der Zwischenzeit eine neue Nachricht bekomme. Weißt du, kannst du dann so ein bisschen...
Wäre das nicht sinnvoller, dass du vor deinem Adium sitzen bleibst und dein iPhone dir sagt, wenn deine Essen fertig ist?
Wenn meine Pizza fertig ist.
Achso, ja, ne, das...
Ja, was wir brauchen sind Herde, twitternde Herde. Und wie, ja, so kühlschränke...
Ich hab heute irgendwas gehört von YellowStrom, der will jetzt twitternde Stromzähler verbauen.
Oh ja, das hab ich auch gelesen, mein Gott.
Wobei ich das ehrlich gesagt für ein Marketing-Gag hatte.
Natürlich ist das ein Marketing-Gag, weil was soll denn das bitte?
Aber eigentlich ist es cool, also von dem Twitter mal abgesehen, aber dass du endlich mal einen Stromzähler hast, der irgendwie seine Daten irgendwie mal statsmäßig rausrückt. Die müssen ja nicht bei Twitter landen, aber eine Webseite mit...
Das ist einfach eine Datenschutzproblematik allererster Güteklasse. Also besser...
Du bist doch hier die Datenschleuder-Sauschlechter.
Ja, aber dann wechsel ich aber das Genre. Ich meine, dann werd ich auch Einbrecher. Also besser kannst du nicht gesagt bekommen, ob irgendjemand zu Hause ist oder nicht, als wenn du deinen Stromzähler aus der Ferne ablesen kannst.
Wann ist er denn nicht zu Hause?
Wenn der Stromverbrauch sinkt.
Wann schlafen die Leute?
Nachts, aber tagsüber wird ja interessant.
Außerdem, wenn bis 22 Uhr oder 23 Uhr noch ein relativ hoher Strom verkommt.
Das beobachtest du einfach mal ein paar Wochen und dann hast du einfach mal so ein geiles Profil.
Ja, aber die müssen ja nicht public sein, die Dinger.
Also, Twitter?
Ja, Twitter ist total albern.
Ja, Twitter ist public.
Da hat sich die einen nachrichten.
Aber vielleicht machen sie es ja auch per DM. Ja, wenn es nicht public ist, dann liegen die Daten halt bei diesem Strom-High-Niveau, wo irgendwelche unterbezahlten Menschen arbeiten, denen du halt dann mal was zusteckst.
Oder das Ding hat einfach einen kleinen Webserver eingebaut und du kannst direkt drauf zu treffen.
Die Leute, die klingeln, wenn einer rangeht, dann brechen sie da nicht ein. Also ich glaube, das ist echt nicht das Problem.
Wie willst du denn noch leichter rausfinden, bei dem ich klingel? Bei allen 500.000 Wohnungen gleichzeitig.
Aber das ist wirklich... Einbrecher geht doch random rum.
Man, aber Tim hat doch echt recht.
Du kannst hier per API eine Software schreiben, die automatisch guckt, wann geht der Stromverbrauch für 4,5 Tage runter und dir die Adressdaten zuschickt.
Dann hat er einen Job, der man auch nicht einbrechen. Außer man bietet das als Service an, natürlich. Für angehende Diebe. Aber mal ehrlich, seitdem ich mein Stromzähl-Messgerät zu Hause hab, also ist ja eigentlich gar nicht meins. Hallo Starbuck. Jedenfalls, seitdem kann ich alles prima durchmessen und hab irgendwie viel weniger Stromverbrauch. Also ich bin der Meinung, dass wenn Leute mehr ihren Stromverbrauch sehen können, dass sie auch viel mehr einsparen. Weil was man nicht sieht, so kommt aus der Dose, der Zähler zählt halt irgendwie den ganzen Tag. Man kriegt irgendwie seinen aktuellen Stromverbrauch immer gar nicht mit. Man kriegt den nur pro Jahr.
Dass du das selbst sehen kannst, okay. Aber nicht andere. Und schon gar nicht deine...
Ja ich sag ja, das Twitter-Feature ist mehr Schnurz, aber dass er sich mal einen Stromzähler einbaut, der seine Daten irgendwo hin rausrückt, dass man mal stattsehen kann, finde ich schon mal einen guten Schritt.
Noch viel praktischer wäre das für Kernkraftwerkbetreiber, wenn die endlich mal rauskriegen, wann ihr Krümel wieder abgestürzt ist. Oh, Kernkraftwerk ist aus!
Die können wir jetzt Proll verwenden.
Haben die ja gar nicht mitbekommen.
Ach Mensch.
Schöne neue Welt. Na jetzt sind wir mitten in der Datenschutz-Thematik.
Ich wünschte dir, dass meine Waschmaschine endlich dran konnte, wenn sie fertig ist. Gibt es da irgendeine Möglichkeit? Wär das nicht mal hier so ein...
Na klar, das kannst du ganz einfach mit einer Webcam machen. Sobald sich das Bild über zwei Minuten lang nicht mehr ändert.
Du meinst komplett vorne, ne? Ich dachte einfach, es hat ja so eine LED, also so eine Anzeige, wo noch steht, wie lange das noch braucht.
Kannst du auch machen, aber du kannst halt einfach normale Motion-Detection mit einem Delay machen. Das können auch alle Kameras heutzutage.
Dann muss ich aber...
Dann kannst du auch einfach eine Webcam von deiner Waschmaschine stellen und dann ab und zu mal gucken.
Muss ich eine Webcam auf meinem Pod installieren? Das ist mein Privacy-Problem. Wenn ich dann auf dem Klo plötzlich eine Webcam stehen habe.
Im Klo? Ich denke dir jetzt um die Waschmaschine.
Ja, die steht im Badezimmer.
Aber die Kamera zeigt ja auf die Waschmaschine, nicht aufs Klo.
Und dann wackelt die Waschmaschine...
Das will ich jetzt gar nicht so genau wissen.
Dann wackelt die Waschmaschine beim Schleudern und der Motion Detection löst dann einen Bruch aus.
Also auf jeden Fall kann ich mir schön vorstellen, wie bei einer Party, wie die Gäste dann so... Mach dir darum keine Sorgen um die Kamera. Die ist nur für die Waschmaschine gut.
Aber nochmal mit dieser Webcam. Du kannst ja wahrscheinlich relativ einfach mit so einem Arduino-System oder so so einem Bastel-Billig-Hardware-Teil und einem einfachen CCD sowas bauen. Dass du es wirklich so davor stellst, dann hat das Ding irgendwie Internet oder WLAN und dann twittert es dich halt wirklich an, wenn dein Waschmaschinenvorgang fertig ist.
Also ich hab...
Aber meine Waschmaschine, die steht im LCD, wann sie fertig ist. Der zählt die Zeit runter. Brauchen wir das gar nicht mehr.
Ja, aber der zählt falsch.
Die Waschmaschine weiß schon vorher, wann sie fertig ist.
Also meine Waschmaschine behauptet das zu wissen.
Also das Programm, was ich immer benutze, hab ich einem eingestellt, braucht 137 Minuten und ab und zu wenn nicht genug Wäsche drin ist, dann wird er mal ein Stück schneller. Aber auf jeden Fall nicht länger.
Also bei mir hat er irgendwie, ich glaube so, da war er schon über 10 Minuten fertig, als er es mir Bescheid gesagt hat. Aber ich hab mich gefragt, ob bei dieser LED, die anzeigt, wie lange er braucht, bei mir steht dann, wenn er fertig ist, steht Enter. Ob man das nicht irgendwie abfragen kann, viel einfacher. Dann hat man da irgendwie ein paar Bits.
Dann sind ja alle verrückt.
Das kann man auf jeden Fall alles feststellen.
Stimmt, lasst uns lieber wieder über Quick-Tang-Geschwindigkeiten reden.
Ja, das war mal interessant. Das war mal was Neues. Das interessiert die Leute. Klar, natürlich.
Hat der nächste iPod eine Kamera?
Das ging ja heute irgendwie so rum.
Sagen wir einfach Ja und Fertig, oder? Ich rechne schwer damit. Ich glaube, sie werden diesem iPod Touch eine Kamera geben. Haben wir da nicht schonmal drüber geredet. Ich denke, sie werden es deshalb tun, weil sie jetzt die Kamera gefunden haben, TM.
Ach, die Kamera?
Die, die sie jetzt verwenden, die lohnt es dann, da verbaut zu werden. Und das gibt dem iPod Touch ein komplett neues Aufgabenspektrum.
Ich glaube, weil sie iPhone und iPod Touch für Entwickler von der Plattform her möglichst identisch machen wollen.
Das kommt dazu. Und natürlich auch einfach das Produkt interessant. Also ich denke auch, dass der Touch immer noch große Abnehmerzahlen finden wird. So gering ist es ja nicht. Ich meine, es werden zwar mehr iPhones verkauft.
Ich glaube, das ist richtig sehr beliebt, oder?
Ja, also es werden mehr iPhone 2 verkauft.
Ein Drittel der iPhone-OS-Installationen waren iPod Touch. Das ist verdammt viel.
Ja, ich glaube, so in der Größenordnung war das.
Überlegen, ein Drittel der Leute rennt da draußen rum und die haben da gar kein Telefon drin. Mir würde ja was fehlen. Und dann WLAN im Wald.
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht haben sie ja so eine mobile Hotspot mit einer SIM-Karte da drin zum ordentlichen Tarif, der einfach einen WLAN-Access-Point aufmacht und dann haben sie irgendwie Skype in der Hosenpoche.
Vielleicht sind sie auch manchmal einfach nur ein bisschen traurig.
Ihr habt doch hier so ein UMTS-Telefon, ne? Wie ist denn dein Zähler für deine, also wir hatten mal noch den Online-Counter hier, wie viel runtergeladen wird ohne WLAN? Das WLAN zählt ja nicht, sondern nur wie viel du über deinen GSM sozusagen oder UMTS runterlässt. Wie hoch ist denn der Zähler bei euch?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, weil ich den resette, um ehrlich zu sein.
Also ich hab ja jetzt nur GPS, aber es sagt ja auch schon was aus. Ich hab seit einem Jahr, circa, ich geh mal hier auf mein Usage, um die aktuellsten Zahlen zu holen, seit einem Jahr habe ich 106 Megabyte runtergeladen.
Ja, du machst aber auch nichts auf dem Ding, oder?
Nee, ich hab immer WLAN, ich hab hier WLAN, ich hab im Club WLAN, ich hab irgendwie überall WLAN. Du gehst dann um Kaffee, WLAN, du bist in Bamberg, du hast WLAN. Na, Einstellungen und dann Usage. Weil ich glaub, man braucht gar nicht so viel OMTS, weil man hat echt schon ganz schön viel WLAN immer.
Und allgemein ist das, ne?
Allgemein, genau, und dann Usage, zweite von oben.
Benutzung. Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, wann ich das das letzte Mal... Wie viel waren's bei dir?
110 Megabyte.
Okay, also bei mir sind gesendet 129 Megabyte und Empfang 1,4 Gig.
Das ist auch nicht so doll viel dafür, dass du richtig schon UMTS hast, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, wann ich das resettet habe, aber ich benutze...
Also ich weiß auch nicht, wann ich das resettet habe. Wieso sagt einem das eigentlich nicht, wenn er das resettet?
Ja, das ist echt doof.
Also hier steht es doch. Letztes Zurücksetzen am...
Ganz unten steht es genau.
5.9.08.
Aber ich hab's noch nie zurückgesetzt.
Das ist auch schon 3,5. Wie viel Gigabyte hast du?
4 Gigabyte Empfang.
Das ist auch nicht so doll viel, oder?
Nö.
Dann kannst du mal sehen, man braucht das nämlich gar nicht so viel.
Nee, hab mich auch überrascht. Das stimmt schon.
Ja, aber wenn, dann will man es schnell haben.
Ja klar, schnell willst du es haben. Dagegen sagt ja keiner was. Aber du, man braucht jetzt zum Beispiel kein Über-Mega-Monster-Ohne-Ende-Mega-Plan.
Nee, wenn ich bedenke, dass ich 10 Gigabyte im Monat habe.
Da hast du noch nicht mal drüber gekommen, wenn es in einem Monat die 4 Gigabyte verhauen ist.
Fällt da Tethering mit drunter?
Ja, das wollte ich mich auch gerade fragen. Also jetzt mit Tethering, da könnte das schon ganz anders aussehen.
Da brennt das nur so durch.
Siehst du, du nutzt also nicht mal die Menge, die du pro Monat hast. Und trotzdem wollen sie für Tethering extra Geld haben. Was ist denn das für ein Scheiß?
Das stimmt, das ist ein sehr extrem valides Argument. Und ich finde das auch wirklich Panne.
Mich würde mal interessieren, ob das überhaupt eigentlich...
Gibt es überhaupt eine Anwendung auf dem iPhone, mit der man wirklich... rumsauen kann, datenmäßig nennenswert?
Na, du kommst nicht leichter in den Store, wenn das machst.
Google World Dingens, wie heißt das?
Google Earth, aber das benutzt du auch nicht schon lang.
Also ich hab...
Nö, aber der lädt ganz schön runter.
Das ist jetzt wirklich so eine Anwendung, die man lange laufen lässt und die auch ohne, dass man die ganze Zeit auf ihr rumtatscht, Datenverkehr erzeugt.
Das lassen sie einfach nicht zu.
Außer YouTube, so Streaming zum Beispiel.
Ich hab ja für eine Bude, die machen so, dass du Fernsehprogramme aufs iPhone runterladen kannst. Unter anderem, also die haben das für alle möglichen Plattformen, unter anderem fürs iPhone. So ein paar Sachen gemacht. Und die haben mir erzählt, dass Apple denen die Software ganz ordentlich um die Ohren gehauen hat.
Was ist mit den ganzen Programmen, die dich direkt zu so einem Radio-Stream connecten?
Zu was zum Beispiel, ja.
Also ich meine, ich stelle eine 5-Stunden-Radio, da kommt schon ein bisschen was rüber.
Also hier F-Stream zum Beispiel.
Ja, aber so viel ist das auch nicht, ne?
Also ich weiß nicht, ob es rechtlich echt okay ist, dass die sagen, du darfst das Tethering, also die Daten, die du kaufst, nur mit dem iPhone benutzen. Was ist denn das, dass du halt deine Schuhe kaufst und die sagen, du darfst die Tonschuhe aber hier nur in unserer Halle benutzen, aber nicht auf der Straße?
Ja, es ist total albern und T-Mobile hat sich damit auch wirklich komplett verspielt, dass ich auch nur darüber nachdenke, zu ihnen zu wechseln. Also das ist einfach diese Attitüde, die stört mich da an der Stelle schon. Das könnte mich halt auch beflügeln, da wieder die erneute Upgrade-Strafgebühr zu bezahlen für moderne Technologie.
Hat es sich denn für dich gelohnt? Ja, ist ja schon ein ganz schön teuer, oder?
Davon ausgehend, dass dieses Gerät ja auch noch einen Wiederverkaufswert hat, muss man das natürlich dann erstmal in Rechnung stellen.
Und du hast jetzt auch ein Jahr lang die Freiheit, eine andere Karte reinzupacken.
Also ich weiß ja nicht, für was die 3Gs derzeit gehandelt werden. Wäre jetzt mein Kopfhörerproblem nicht?
Das muss ja keinem sagen.
Das muss ich keinem sagen. Ich bitte dich. Ich bin doch ein aufrichtiger eBayer. Das kann man nicht machen. Ich muss dieses Teil erstmal wieder heile kriegen.
Das schreiben doch alle so rein.
Ja, ich...
Ich werd dir ein kaputtes Malendrie-Wart verkaufen.
Okay, ich werd denn jetzt nie was abkaufen.
Ich denke der Trend geht auch zum Zweitphone, also das...
Zum Backupphone, ja?
Zum Backupphone.
Also ich fände so nach...
Wir sollten das einfach auf Original-Mobile-Max-iPhone versteigern.
Also ein Backupphone zu haben, finde ich generell gut. Ich hatte eigentlich immer ein Backupphone. Und derzeit habe ich kein Backupphone. Und gleich so etwas als Backup zu haben, ist vielleicht ein bisschen Luxus, aber es...
Aber man muss ja auch mal sagen...
Ist das ganze Leben nicht ein einziger Luxus irgendwo?
Ganz mal kurz zwischendurch bemerkt, wenn man jetzt, wenn man vor einem Jahr sich ein iPhone 3G geholt hat und jetzt das neue upgraden will, offiziell über der Telekom, dann hat man ja auch sich richtig schön einmal in den Arsch gebissen. Weil... Das ist ja... Den aktuellen Vertrag kann man ja nicht. Also man kriegt ja einfach keins. Man muss ja eine Ablösegebühr zahlen, für die Restlaufzeit des Vertrags.
Das ist so was wie pro Monat 25 Euro oder so was?
Genau, dafür muss der Vertrag aber schon...
Mindestens die Jahraltzeit oder sowas, ne?
Nee, ich glaube ein bisschen länger als ein Jahr.
18 Monate?
Echt länger auch noch.
Und also so, dass man eigentlich jetzt auch nochmal ein bisschen warten kann. Und wenn man dann diese Ablösegebühr bezahlt hat, was hat man dann? Dann hat man ein iPhone mit SimLog, was dann wieder nur bei T-Mobile geht.
Nee, das kann man aber auch wegmachen lassen, oder?
Nee, nach 24 Monaten. Mit NetLog, genau.
Man muss trotzdem dann noch warten.
Man muss dann trotzdem noch warten. Das heißt, dann kann man dann noch ein halbes Jahr lang oder so dieses iPhone in der Schublade liegen lassen, zugucken, wie es an Wert verliert und kann es dann verkloppen, wenn der SimLog, der NetLog ist.
Und immer noch kein Europatarif.
Und du kannst noch nicht mal deine neue T-Mobile-Karte in das alte Phone reinstecken. Das geht nämlich nicht.
Das müsste gehen, oder?
Nee, da habe ich auch irgendwas gelesen. Das würde dann auch noch nicht mehr funktionieren.
Das wäre natürlich dann komplett. Also es gibt ja, man kann ja bei Media Markt, habe ich nämlich neulich gesehen, kann man ja ein iPhone kaufen mit Prepaid-Tarif?
Weiß ich noch mal, bei Media Markt kann man iPhones?
Die haben so einen kleinen T-Mobile-Store, aber auch da steht dann drin. Genau, das ist irgendwie also einfach eine so eine Säule, wo dann nur T-Mobile dran steht. Und nee, das war nicht Media Markt, das war Medimarkt oder ich weiß nicht, irgendein Technikmarkt.
Aber die sind auch genitlogged, das ist genau das Gleiche.
Genau, die sind auch für 24 Monate genitlogged.
Das ist alles Scheiße und es stinkt, das wollen wir gar nicht haben.
Wo ist Deins jetzt eigentlich her gewesen? Aus der Tschechei?
Nee, das ist auch ein italienisches.
Und Deins ist ja noch gar nicht rot auf der Rückseite.
Ich mein's noch gar nicht rot auf der Rückseite.
Warum nicht?
Weil ich diesen hässlichen, diese Tasche nicht habe. Oh Gott, wollen wir mal was zu iPhone Taschen erzählen? Das ist ja auch noch ein Thema für sich.
Wir sollten nochmal unsere iPhone Themen mal irgendwie zu Ende kriegen. Wir müssen nämlich noch so ein bisschen, glaube ich, über Meta-Themen reden.
Stimmt. Also es gab ja irgendwie, waren ja so von den iPhones 3GS, waren ja einige hinten plötzlich rosa und das haben sich alle darüber, also von den Weißen, dass die plötzlich so einen leichten rosaen Touch haben. Das hat sich heute jetzt aufgeklärt, oder?
Aufgeklärt nicht, aber da hat einer gemeint, das wäre nur seine Hülle gewesen. Er hat sie mit Alkohol irgendwie sauber gemacht und dann war sie weg.
Das ist die offizielle Empfehlung vom Apple Support mittlerweile. Und ich habe mir...
Da war bestimmt die erste Story auch nur, um irgendwie mal eine Story zu haben, oder? Weil der hat das bestimmt gewusst, dass es von seiner Tasche kommt.
Nein, es waren ja mehrere, bei denen das war.
Ja, und die hatten alle eine rote Tasche und das ist ihr nicht aufgefallen?
Naja, nee, muss ja nicht zwangsläufig. Kann ja sein, dass da irgendwie Chemikalie drin ist, die dann langsam rausdunstet bei Temperatur und dann sich irgendwie verfärbt oder so. Weiß nicht, ob die rot war. Auf jeden Fall hab ich mal, weil ich hab jetzt gesehen, wie ein runtergefallenes iPhone aussieht und es macht, so mit gesplittertem Display, und es macht mehr Schmerzen als einem fremden Kind beim Stolpern zu sehen. Und hab darum beschlossen, dass ich unbedingt, damit dieses iPhone nicht kaputt geht, eine iPhone-Hülle brauche. Hab zwei verschiedene iPhone-Hüllen ausprobiert. Und wie ihr seht, ich hab keine davon. Weil die sind ja so scheiße iPhone-Hülle.
Ich hab schon mein Leben lang irgendwie meine Phones ohne Hülle. Und ja, die sind auch ab und zu mal schon runtergefallen, aber nie wirklich schlimm. Und alle Leute wundern sich, warum mein iPhone noch so gut aussieht, weil, obwohl es keine Hülle hat. Irgendwie geh ich dafür dann auch ordentlich damit um. Ich weiß auch nicht.
Naja, es ist ja, also hier mit diesem Glas-Display, wenn das einmal falsch auf die Frontseite fällt, dann hast du Schrott. Das ist einfach so. Und auch wenn das irgendwie so auf die Kante fällt oder so ungünstig, dann kriegst du einfach...
Angeblich ein Ersatz-Display bei Apple kostet irgendwie, also neu reinmachen lassen, kostet 200 Dollar.
Das kriegst du, wenn du es in Deutschland machen lässt, von T-Mobile. Ich kenn jemand, der hat das Spielchen jetzt gerade hinter sich, dann bist du irgendwie, ich glaube, bei 400 dabei. 400 Euro.
Aber dafür krieg ich doch ein neues. Jep.
Aber nicht von der Telekom, weil da musst du ja die Ablösesumme und so weiter und so fort.
Also das ist auch ganz schön abzocke.
Der hat sich dann bei eBay ein Ersatzdisplay bestellt, für, ich glaube, 35 Euro. Und hat das einen befreundeten Techniker machen lassen, der das dann auch umgesetzt hat und der ist jetzt ganz glücklich wieder, hat jetzt ein heiles iPhone.
Die Scheibe ist irgendwie die gleiche Quality oder sogar vom gleichen Hersteller?
Ich würde mal vermuten, dass die vom selben Hersteller ist, dass der die einfach verkloppt.
Ich kann nur hoffen, dass es mit T-Mobile Mitte 2010 dann auch vorbei ist. Dass es also zum nächsten Generationswechsel dieser Vertrag ausläuft. Da gab es ja so ein Gerücht, das geht nur bis 2009, dann haben sie irgendwie eine Weile rumgedruckst. Meinten sie sowieso, nein, es würde ja auch über 2009 hinausgehen, aber wie lange haben sie dann wirklich nicht gesagt?
Das musst du deswegen machen, damit jetzt nicht alle noch irgendwie das halbe Jahr warten, bis es eigentlich vorbei ist.
Ende 2009 habe ich eh nicht geglaubt, weil dann warten sie den kompletten Lifecycle ab und wenn es eine neue Modellgeneration gibt, ändert sich was. Die machen das ja nicht mittendrin. ich halte es jetzt auch nicht für ausgeschlossen, dass das irgendwann auch mal vorbei ist, der Spuk. Weil das kann ja auch nun nicht ewig so weitergehen. Ich finde mittlerweile ist jetzt die Einführung des iPhones eigentlich abgeschlossen. Das Gerät ist jetzt da. die Leute wollen es einfach haben. Mann. Ohne nach Belgien fahren zu müssen. Das ist ja echt eh albern. Batterielebensdauer habe ich mir notiert. Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, was ich sagen wollte damit. Aber ich hoffe ja, dass es bei dem neuen iPhone 3GS besser ist. Bei mir ist es schon immer noch suboptimal. Und wenn man halt so Tätering und Tralala macht, dann ist halt irgendwie so mit Akku echt nicht mehr viel zu holen.
Und hast du denn hier Push-Notification an?
Nee.
Hast du auch richtig ausgemacht daher? In den Einstellungen.
Ich wüsste jetzt einfach nicht, was ich mir so pushen lassen würde.
Es gibt nicht so wahnsinnig viele Push-Applikationen.
Also Java würde ich machen, aber erst wenn es halt irgendwie eine Lösung gibt, wo ich nicht irgendwie auf irgendeinem komischen Server...
Also das ist schick, das Dove ist bloß, man muss halt unbedingt den Leuten vorher klar machen, dass man, also man muss das irgendwie in die Notiz reinschreiben, du, es kann sein, dass ich einfach nicht drauf reagiere, weil es passiert mir jetzt regelmäßig, dass ich auf dem Fahrrad sitze und mitkriege, dass mich jemand anchattet, was einfach total nervig ist.
Naja, jetzt mit Preul kannst du dir ja richtig sinnlose Sachen schicken.
Genau.
Du machst dir echt noch Sorgen über deinen Online-Status? Ich nicht mehr. Also ich hab meine Kiste zu Hause den ganzen Tag an und wenn ich dann mal eine Stunde einkaufen gehe, gehe ich eine Stunde einkaufen, das ist mir doch egal.
Mir ist nicht egal, was meine Mitmenschen, wie die mit mir kommunizieren.
Ich müsste halt dann mal ein bisschen warten.
Also ich hätte auch ganz gern so einen Button an meinem an meinem Gürtel, den ich so offline, AFK und online schalten könnte. Und dementsprechend folgt mir dann sozusagen die ganze technische Infrastruktur irgendwie nach.
Ich finde das aber noch nicht optimal gelöst, wenn man zum Beispiel, also es funktioniert so halbwegs, was ganz furchtbar ist mit diesem B-Jive, und zwar wenn man den AOL Instant Messenger benutzt, der teilt einem immer noch per Nachricht mit, dass man jetzt an zwei Locations gleichzeitig eingeloggt ist.
Immer noch.
Und es gibt auch keine Möglichkeit, das abzuschalten. Und ich hab auf dem Adium, hab ich es einfach geblockt. Hier in B-Jive hat das irgendwie mit dem Blocken nicht funktioniert. Ich hab mich jetzt einfach damit, das Problem damit gelöst, dass ich auf dem iPhone kein IEM mehr nutze. Geht sterben, mir wurscht. Mit Google Talk geht es so halbwegs. Da übernimmt er quasi immer den Status von dem nächsthöhergerankten. Also er quatscht, wenn man Adium offen hat und da auf Anwesend ist. Und auf dem iPhone ist man auf Abwesend geschaltet. Dann ist man im Internet online, auf Anwesend. Und die erste Nachricht erscheint auf beiden Geräten. Und danach erscheinen die restlichen Nachrichten, wo man gerade antwortet. Das ist eigentlich ganz praktisch.
Dennis, du hattest jetzt noch irgendwie P2P-Bluetooth gesagt?
Ja, weil ich ja gerade Flight Control gespielt hab ein bisschen.
Was ist denn das eigentlich?
Na, Flight Control ist irgendwie das. So ein kleines Spiel kostet irgendwie zur Zeit glaube ich noch einen Dollar, also 80 Cent hier.
Was ist das wieder? Tower Defense oder was?
Nee, da ist ein Flughafen mit einer Landebahn, so ein runder Platz für noch einen Hubschrauber und so eine Mini-Landebahn für so Doppelflügler oder wie die heißen, so kleine Propeller-Dinger. Also große Flugzeuge, kleine Flugzeuge und Hubschrauber, die kommen so rangeflogen vom Rand und du musst sie mit so einem Fingerswipe ihre Linie malen, sodass sie auf ihrer Landebahn irgendwie ankommen. Und dann gibt es für jedes gelandete Fluggerät gibt es halt einen Punkt. Und ich hab es gerade mal geschafft bis 60. Meine Kumpel ist irgendwie der beste Rekord, ist bei 78. Und das wurde von Apple gehypt irgendwie oder überhaupt an sich. Hat sich rumgesprochen, war wochenlang auf Platz eins. Und die Bude, die das rausgegeben hat, die haben auch mal so ein Statistik-PDF rausgerückt. Sie meinten, sie haben es innerhalb von fünf oder sieben Wochen 700.000 Mal verkauft. Und der Typ, der es programmiert hat, meint, der hat es zwischen Weihnachten 2008 und Neujahr irgendwie geschrieben. Also innerhalb von einer Woche. Wahrscheinlich pusht Apple das so, weil sie es halt als Werbung nimmt. Guck mal, du kannst in einer Woche ein Spiel programmieren und machst irgendwie eine halbe Million Dollar Gewinn. Das ist einfach ein schön gemachtes Programm.
Ja, macht es süchtig irgendwie.
Es macht so ein bisschen süchtig.
Das ist gut, dann kauf ich mit.
Max ist nur 33.
Aber du hast dir Geld ausgegeben für Software. Dennis?
Na, ich war in Bamberg, da war langweilig.
Siehst du, Convenience und Boredom, das ist das, was das Business treibt im Internet.
So, ja, aber jetzt kommt ja die eigentliche Geschichte, worauf wir hinaus wollen. Die neueste Version von Flight Control kann jetzt auch, mit OS-Version 3.0, kann halt dieses Bluetooth Peer-to-Peer irgendwie zocken, irgendwie erlauben, wie auch immer das denn im Spiel aussieht, weil ich kann es nicht testen, weil anscheinend geht dieses Bluetooth Peer-to-Peer nicht mit dem First-Generation-iPhone.
Richtig, weil du nämlich nur Bluetooth 2.1 und nicht 3.0 oder nur Bluetooth 2.0 oder nicht 2.1 hast.
Ja, was ist denn daran anders?
Das kann ich dir jetzt gerade aus dem Kopf nicht sagen.
Also, dass so ein Peering ohne Peering nicht geht, habe ich irgendwie noch nicht gewusst.
Kann das denn auch über WLAN machen alternativ? Hast du das auch auf deinem iPhone, Maxi? Flight Control?
Ja, das können wir gerne mal testen.
Dann können wir das gleich mal testen.
Also ich habe irgendwo eine Beschreibung gelesen, man muss dann auch nicht nur auf Flughilfen landen, die Flugzeuge, sondern manchmal muss man sie eben auch zu dem Display für den anderen schicken.
Ach und dann muss der die landen?
Ich hab noch ein...
Ist auf jeden Fall ein nettes Spiel, ist billig, macht irgendwie Spaß. Das ist so ein, wie heißt es, ein Kumpel von mir, der sich irgendwie mit Games beschäftigt. Easy to learn und hard to master.
Man hat irgendwie die ersten Level schon so ein bisschen Erfolgserlebnisse.
Es gibt keine Level. Es ist auch immer gleich und eigentlich angeblich wird es auch nicht schwerer. Da bin ich aber noch nicht so überzeugt von.
Das wird ja immer mehr.
Ja, immer mehr, weil du die nicht schnell genug irgendwie gehandelt kriegst, aber eigentlich nicht so wirklich. Da müsstest du halt mal messen, wie viel da pro Sekunde oder alle, wie viel Sekunden eins reinkommt.
Ja, wollen wir fortschreiten? Also ich hab noch was anderes getan und zwar, ich bin ja auch, also für Convenience und Boredom, irgendwie das passt bei mir manchmal auch. Und ich bereite mich ja hier auch gerade mal wieder auf eine Phase vor, wo ich erhöhten Medienkonsum auf meinem Telefon haben werde. Und da hat man immer das Problem, dann will man halt so Fernsehserien komplett staffelweise haben. Und dann ist man ja immer so in diesem Spannungsfeld der Illegalität. Ihr werdet schon mal davon gehört haben. Wenn man so komplette Fernsehstaffeln haben will.
Ach so, das lässt man sich auf Hardmedien zuschicken oder?
Naja, Hardmedien fällt komplett aus. Ich will Softmedien haben. Ich wohne ja im 21. Jahrhundert.
Das Problem ist auch, dass man ja ordentliche Quality haben will.
Genau, man will ordentliche Quality haben. Und im iTunes Store kann man die ja kaufen.
Aber noch nicht in HD, oder?
Nö, nicht in HD.
Und dann wieder nur in Deutsch?
Nein, du kriegst auch englische Serien.
Welche Serien? Das sind ja noch im legalen Bereich.
Das sind so einige, aber das Allermeiste davon interessiert mich halt nicht die Bohne. Und ich hab jetzt einfach aus Prinzip mal, weil auch der Preis, naja zumindest nicht vollständig neben der Tasse war, hab ich mir mal die zweite Staffel von Heroes gekauft. Was so jetzt rein von der Shopping Experience ganz geil ist, weil du sagst halt einfach kaufen, das waren irgendwie 25 Euro oder so, für keine Ahnung, 13 Folgen oder so. Also immerhin 13 mal, wie lange sind die Dinger? 40 Minuten, 45 Minuten. Also schon signifikant viele Stunden Entertainment. Wenn man das jetzt mal mit dem Kinobesuch vergleicht, dann würde ich sagen, das ist schon irgendwie im Rahmen. Also so zweimal ins Kino gehen und dafür kriegst du halt 10 Stunden.
Es ist eher so einmal ins Kino gehen.
Einmal ins Kino gehen? 25 Euro? Ach so, meinst du mit Popcorn und Cola und so? Na gut, heute fress ich ja vielleicht zu Hause auch.
Aber billiger. Weil die Preise, die da so eine Cola nehmen, das ist ja... Also das ist wirklich...
Da ist was dran. Da ist was dran.
Ein Verbrechen. Das sind die wahren Kriminellen nämlich. Ja, hast du mal gesehen, was da die Sachen kosten, die die einem da andrehen wollen?
Ja klar, ich bin regelmäßig im Kino.
Und wie viel kosten die?
Relativ viel.
Genau. Das ist ganz schön sehr viel. Also das ist ja teurer als auf der Grünen Woche oder auf der CeBIT oder so.
Nein, ein A-Quart-Stunden glaub ich teuer ist das nicht.
Komm, sobald ich ins Kino mal geht. Klar, als ihr in so einen kleinen Kinos, da geht's noch. Aber so, mal wenn du in so einen Cubics gehen musst oder sowas, weil der Film nirgends anders läuft, dann musst du euch ganz schön Fälle bezahlen.
Also zwischen 2,50 und 3,50 für ein Bier würde ich mal sagen.
Ist ja auch vollkommen egal. Tatsache ist, man kann gespaltener Meinung darüber sein, welchen Wert das jetzt sozusagen hat. Aber das war jetzt für mich auch einfach mal so der Kauf. Ich wollte jetzt mal einfach das mal tun. Bin einfach rein in diesen Store, hab gesagt, bitte keine deutsche Scheiße. Ich will hier Originale haben, gab's. Und dann hab ich die halt irgendwie runtergeladen bekommen. Diese zwei sind glaube ich 11 Episoden. Gut, und das waren dann irgendwie glaube ich 25 Euro. Ich weiß jetzt alles nicht mehr so ganz genau. Also zahlst du halt ungefähr so 230, 250 Euro pro Folge. Also wenn man es jetzt auf Kino-Länge macht, ist es immer noch der halbe Preis. Kann man natürlich darüber argumentieren, ist jetzt irgendwie so Fernsehserie, hat das so dieselbe Dichte wie so ein Kino-Abend? Hat's wahrscheinlich nicht, gar keine Frage. Aber dafür ist halt auch alles irgendwie convenient und schnell und tralala. Und das lädt ja auch in Windes alle runter. Ich meine, mit diesen Ackermaiservern, die sie irgendwie am Start haben, das sind immer so die Momente, wo ich wirklich feststellen kann, was ich eigentlich für eine Bandbreite zu Hause habe. Weil dann rauscht's halt einfach wirklich mit 1,4 Megabyte pro Sekunde auf die Platte und dann gehst du mal kurz aufs Klo und tralala. So, wie auch immer. Jetzt war es aber so, dass auch wirklich nur diese Staffel dazu kriegen war, die zweite. Und die erste...
War die denn auf Englisch oder auf Deutsch?
Auf Englisch. Na, auf Deutsch kriegst du natürlich noch viel mehr. Aber wenn ich mir ehrlich gesagt das anschaue, was sie da haben, da möchte ich auf die Tastatur kotzen. Da ist dieser ganze Stinkekack, der hier wohl offensichtlich... Also da merkt man dann wieder, was in diesem Fernsehen läuft.
Also ich hab ja eine Staffel von Ladykracher gekauft, fand ich früher nicht ganz so schlecht, wie jetzt auf den iTunes.
Gut, your mileage may vary. Also für mich ist das irgendwie nix. Also dieser ganze Doktorsch-Scheiß und was die da... Also das ist mir einfach zu dumm. Und damit kann ich irgendwie nicht leben. Und so dieses High-End-Serien-Entertainment, was da gerade in den USA so hip ist, das finde ich, das zieht schon. Nicht, dass das jetzt alles irgendwie toll und großartig ist, aber da kann ich mich einfach entspannen. Und das finde ich auch spannend genug, um dem irgendwie zu folgen. Und ich finde es auch lustig genug, um unterhalten zu sein, wie auch immer. So, jetzt gibt es aber natürlich auch die dritte Staffel. Und wie das halt so ist, obwohl es die halt gibt seit Ewigkeiten, gibt es die da nicht. Du kannst sie da einfach nicht kaufen.
Von was?
Heroes.
Nie gehört?
Doch, war Schrott.
Ich finde Heroes super. Wie auch immer. Kann man ja gespaltener Meinung sein. Ist halt Fernsehen. Und so, wollte ich aber jetzt haben. Da jetzt hatte ich irgendwie die zweite durch. Man will sie einfach haben.
Ha, man weiß schon, was er gemacht hat.
Na klar, da habe ich die Segel gesetzt. Und wie ein guter Pirat in See gestochen. Und?
Und dann hast du auch gleich das Torrent gefunden, wo einmal komplett alles HD Blu-ray-Rip, irgendwie 1080p+.
Nein, diesen Blu-ray-Kram, den lade ich mir nicht runter, weil erstens bräuchte das für mein iPhone sowieso nicht. Zweitens, und jetzt, da beginnt nämlich jetzt das Elend, und jetzt komme ich auch sozusagen auf das, worauf ich eigentlich hinaus war.
Alles MKV, oder?
Ja, Blu-ray ist natürlich alles MKV. Und mit MKV ist mein Ergebnis noch schlechter als schon mit Avis, weil letztlich brauch ich es ja in H264. Das ist zwar teilweise H264.
Aber anders verpackt.
Aber mit unklarem Profil und meistens eben dann auch gleich mit dem Main Profile. Was halt auch nicht, also ich weiß nicht genau, auf dem iPhone geht schon eine ganze Menge. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, aber alle Features von Main Profile kann der auch nicht. Der kann schon mehr als Base Profile, aber es ist nicht wahr. So, das heißt ich brauch's halt in einem bestimmten Zahl H264. Darf eine bestimmte Bitrate nicht überschreiten.
Du guckst an eine Serie wirklich auf dem iPhone?
Ja, ich guck's vor allem abends zum Schlafengehen so. Das ist so für mich.
Im Bett.
Ja, im Bett mit dieser üblichen...
Und du kriegst ja nicht Augenschmerzen, weil man so nah dran hält?
Na, wenn du Augenschmerzen kriegst, hältst du halt weiter weg.
Dann seh ich ja nix mehr.
Nö. Also bevor ich da Augenschmerzen kriege, bin ich eingeschlafen. Ich versteh. Nee, auch wenn ich unterwegs bin, guck ich sowas. Also, was weiß ich, sitz halt im Zug, sitz halt in der Straßenbahn, irgendwas. Also ich find das einfach convenient, insbesondere jetzt mit den Bluetooth-Kopfhörern. Also die sind nicht so praktisch, weil die zu bald gehen, sind jetzt fürs Bett. Aber so für unterwegs ist das geil. Weil da hast du halt einfach... Das größte Problem über der ganzen Sache ist eigentlich, wie du dein iPhone aufstellst. Die ganze Zeit festhalten willst. Aber Fernseher hab ich nicht und ich meine, wo soll ich es mir sonst angucken? Auf dem Computer? Ach nee. Da kann ich ja noch nicht mal eben in die Küche gehen. Ich kann mir das ja hier anschauen, bin ja die ganze Zeit mobil.
Wenn ich in die Küche gehe, drück ich kurz Pause, gehe in die Küche und komm wieder.
Pause, das ist ja Feigheit vor dem Feind.
Ja, du läufst da irgendwie mit deinem kleinen Zeh gegen die Wand.
Ach blödsinn.
Klar.
Nein, doch, nein, doch, nein, doch. Anyway, jetzt kommen wir zu dem eigentlichen Problem. Das Problem ist, wie kriegt man die Scheiße konvertiert? Aha, dachte ich auch.
Aber?
Also meine Ergebnisse mit verschiedenen Tools, die ich so über die Zeit getestet habe. Also erstens, ich will nicht so ewig dran rumfummeln und mir tausend Profile überlegen. Gibt es schon fernes Profil? Ja, aber dann gibt es auch fünf Settings, die irgendwie in Frage kommen.
Nee, eins.
Ja, was eins?
Das Problem bei Handbrake war, dass sie von einer Version zur nächsten ihre Profiles neu gemacht haben und das auch drin steht, dass wenn man da nicht irgendwie alle tausend haben will, dass man erstmal seine alten Profiles alle löschen soll, damit er die neuen anzeigt.
Wie auch immer das Problem ist, dass einfach in dieser Avi-Landschaft ist einfach so viel Dreck, so viel mies encodeter Scheiß drin, nicht jetzt so sehr vom Video-Encoding, sondern sozusagen von der Gesamtkonstellation mit den ganzen Metadaten und so, dass ich einfach sehr, sehr häufigen, das war dann eben gerade bei dieser Heroes-Staffel wieder so, hab ich halt einfach was weiß ich, Syncing-Probleme, dann läuft dann halt einfach über die dreiviertel Stunde läuft der Ton einfach um zehn Sekunden davon. Das hatte ich mit Handbrake. Und ich hab verschiedene andere Tools getestet. Ich hab früher mir mal ein Tool gekauft für 10 Dollar, das hieß erst Potná, dann haben sie es umbenannt in Widi Up. Richtig schöner Scheißname. Wird leider nichts mehr dran gemacht. War auch sehr langsam. Also hat wirklich, wirklich, wirklich lange gedauert und war eigentlich unerträglich. Und jetzt hab ich so verschiedene Tools getestet und jetzt ist mir ein neues, was derzeit noch in Beta ist, über den Weg gelaufen, was einerseits sehr einfach ist, andererseits hervorragende Konvertierergebnisse macht ohne irgendwie Sync-Probleme. Zumindest aus all den AVs, die ich da draufgeschmissen habe. Und was auch noch sehr schnell ist. Und das heißt EVOM. EVOM? E-V-O-M. EVOM ist noch irgendwie in Beta. Und scheint mir derzeit so die beste Lösung, oder zumindest die für mich derzeit beste Lösung zu sein für dieses Problem mit, ich will mal jetzt eben diese Videos schnell in iPhone, iPod kompatibel. Der hat auch noch verschiedene andere Settings als Target. Aber so mit den Defaults läuft es einfach wunderbar.
Aber sag mal, unten drunter benutzen doch auch alle FFmpeg und sogar Unix Command Line Tools, die sie dann remote steuern, oder?
Im Falle von Eworm ist es so. Der lädt sich auch von Zeit zu Zeit mal eine neue Version separat runter, wenn er in den Start ist. Also nicht von sich selbst, sondern eben von dem FFmpeg Kram.
Irgendjemand hat noch ein Video-Mang geimpft von mir gerade.
Es mag da noch andere Tools geben. Das habe ich halt jetzt mal getestet. Und das ist noch im Development. Das hat auch ein super, super, mega simples Interface. Aber deswegen finde ich es gerade so reizvoll.
Bookmarklets für YouTube-Download oder Flash-Download. Das ist ja mal eine schöne Sache. At one click Flash-Downloads from the web? Fragezeichen auf der evo.com Homepage. Das ist ein kleines Bookmarklet. Und ich nehme mal an, das wird dafür sorgen, dass man dann die Sachen sofort auf dem iPhone sind, was man sich darunter lädt.
Bei YouTube?
Zum Beispiel?
Das ist ja nichts Neues, dass bei YouTube alles als H264 iPhone-kompatibel rumliegt.
Nee, aber ich nehme mal an, dass dieses Bookmarklet das Zeug runterlädt, wenn es ein FLV ist, dann daraus ein H264 macht und der das dann in deine iPhone-Bibliothek schmeißt oder so.
Das musst du da gar nicht draus machen, das ist bei YouTube sowieso schon.
Ja, aber es geht nicht nur um YouTube.
Achso, es geht um alles Mögliche.
Es geht um alles Mögliche.
Okay.
Your mileage may vary. Also ich finde, das funktioniert. Die haben zumindest ihren Encoding-Kram im Griff. Scheint mir so derzeit zu sein. Tja, womit wir bei der Piratenbucht werden, da müssen wir jetzt auf jeden Fall noch mal drüber reden. Jetzt haben wir jetzt so lange hier bei McIntosh geschnattet, können wir auch mal auf die Metaebene gehen. Max, was hast du denn mitbekommen?
Was hab ich denn mitbekommen? Oh Gott, das ist jetzt wie in der Schule damals.
Oh mein Gott, was, was, was, was?
Lick mal das Comic-Heft beiseite.
Aber das ist doch mein Schulbuch.
Auf dein Zimmer.
Die Pirate Bay ist verkauft worden.
Soll verkauft werden.
Soll verkauft werden. Für absolut wenig Geld eigentlich. Wie viel waren's? 5,4 Millionen oder so? Und ich hab gehört, so Gerüchteweise, dass da was im Busch sei. Weil, merkwürdig, die, die das kaufen wollen, die haben ja nicht so viel Geld. Und irgendwie gibt's so eine Menge Gerüchte, dass das wohl gar nicht so ein totaler Verkauf ist wie...
Also du Stora ist genauso im Dunkeln wie die meisten.
Ich stochere absolut im Dunkeln.
Du Stora ist auch im Dunkeln.
Ich weiß da auch nicht wirklich mehr.
Ja, also ich hab auch noch kein wirkliches Installerwissen, aber ich hab mir einfach mal die Sache ein bisschen angeschaut. Und es gab auch den Podcast da mit dem Peter, der bei Netzpolitik war. Und grundsätzlich ist es wohl so. Diese ganze... Also die letzte Aktivität in diesem Pirate Bay Fall war ja, dass diese Befangenheitsantrag des Richters abgelehnt wurde. Und irgendwie sieht es jetzt so aus, oder würde ich es zumindest nicht ausschließen wollen, dass diese ganze Verurteilung tatsächlich ihren Weg nimmt.
Ne, gibt's ja noch Berufung.
Ja, es gibt Berufung, aber...
Und da gibt's ja auch mehrere Instanzen noch. Das kann auch hier lang dauern.
Klar, aber sagen wir's mal anders. Es zeichnet sich ab, dass das Modell Pirate Bay, so wie es bisher gelaufen ist, juristisch auf eine Art und Weise angreifbar ist, dass sie sich eine andere Strategie überlegen müssen. Dazu kommt wahrscheinlich auch noch eine gewisse Ermüdung jetzt nach fünf Jahren der Präsenz und der Arbeit. Und die Jungs haben, glaube ich, irgendwie auch mal Bock auf einen Change. So, dieser Verkauf allerdings ist ominös, weil die Aussage war, dass sie so schon 2006 quasi das Ownership an Pirate Bay an andere Leute ausgelagert haben. Die jetzt sozusagen das verkauft haben, allerdings nicht die Einnahmen wirklich erhalten, sondern Teil dieses Deals war schon immer, dass das Geld an eine Stiftung geht. Das heißt, das, was jetzt stattfindet, ist eigentlich schon seit drei Jahren so festgelegt gewesen. Und diese Stiftung soll halt mit dem Geld Dinge tun.
Unter anderem halt die Rechnung des Traffic bezahlen.
Ja, die sind wahrscheinlich nicht unerheblich, oder?
Die dürften ganz schön hoch sein.
Aber so richtig wissen tust du es auch nicht. Weißt du, wie groß der Traffic ist?
Ich hab mal was von 1,2 Gigabit gehört.
Pro was?
Achso, sustained. 1,2 Gigabit.
Das ist viel.
Schon nicht wenig, ich kenn keinen, der so viel verbraucht. Als Einzelseite. Weiß nicht, was der Spiegel aufwies.
Podcast-Hoster haben sowas auch.
Ja, okay, aber es sind ja schon wieder Unternehmen, die sich so auf, also die haben ja nicht ein Podcast, die haben ja irgendwie so ein Riesensortiment und viele Kunden, die das halt irgendwie bezahlen.
Na klar, das wird bezahlt.
Ja, eben so. Das sind ja auch nur so Mittelmänner, aber Pirate Bay ist ja kein Mittelmänner, das ist deren Dienst und so, die müssen diese 1,2 Gigabit bezahlen. So, die zahlen die halt über die Werbung.
Wobei der Großtrail ist da halt der Tracker.
Würde ich gar nicht mal sagen. Naja, die ganzen Abrufe auf der Suche. Also, ich bin mir nicht so sicher, was der größere Anteil ist, kann ich nicht so genau sagen.
Naja, auf Tatsache ist, mit diesem Deal geht halt die Verfügung über die Domain und quasi sozusagen über die Webseite. Aber dieser Treckerdienst gehört nicht dazu. Das heißt, der Treckerdienst wird eingestellt.
So, und da frage ich mich, wie du das machen wollen, weil die Webseite verursacht Traffic, den müssen die dann weiter bezahlen, weil das ist ja dann deren, haben sie ja mitgekauft. So, aber der Tracker macht halt auch Traffic, der muss auch bezahlt werden. Wenn sie den aber nicht mitkaufen, wer bezahlt dann den Traffic von dem Trecker?
Ja, es wird einfach kein Parade-Bait-Trecker mehr geben.
Ja, aber wer macht den dann? Das kann sich keiner leisten, der nicht Geld verdient.
Wer den macht, weiß ich nicht, aber sie haben halt jetzt openbittorrent.com Und mit einem Trecker kann man kein Geld verdienen, sonst hätte ich welches. Nee, aber so ein offener Trecker könnte halt durch solche Spenden, z.B. von so einer Stiftung, bezahlt werden. Das wäre ja schon mal so ein Modell.
Da hat aber noch, also da habe ich noch nichts weiter von gehört bisher.
Nee, aber es gibt halt jetzt openbittorrent.com und da sagen die halt irgendwie, wir haben hier einen offenen Trecker, wir wissen von nichts irgendwie, benutzt uns, la la la. Das heißt letztlich genau dieselbe Policy, wie das bisher mit dem Pirate Bay Trecker auch war. Und das heißt, sie trennen das. Was ja bei Mininova schon immer der Fall war, da gab es schon immer die Search-Site. In meiner Meinung nach auch besser funktioniert als die von Pirate Bay. Ich finde die Suche bei Pirate Bay war einfach schon immer unterirdisch.
Na Pirate Bay ist ja auch keine Meta-Suche, Mininova ist ja, obwohl es Mininova auch Meta, ja doch, die suchen ja überall, so wie Isohunt, die auch eine Meta-Suche sind. Die suchen bei allen anderen.
Ist ja egal, aber wie die Suche funktioniert. Also du gibst da Keywords ein und fragst dich manchmal, welche Bits er da miteinander verglichen hat.
Bei Mininova und Isohunt Sachen auf Pirate Bay, die Pirate Bay selber nicht findet.
Ja, ja. Mit demselben Suchen.
Das ist aber oft schon andersrum.
Ja, aber das ist wirklich so 90-10.
Das kann schon sein.
Wie auch immer. Also Pirate Bay ist auf jeden Fall in einem verbesserungswürdigen Zustand. Das sagen sie ja auch selber. Sie wollen den Trecker jetzt nicht mehr benutzen, so wie Mininova das auch nicht gemacht hat.
Ich muss ja auch sagen, die Webseite, also die Suche ist nicht von Erdgeist.
Achso, aber ja nicht behauptet.
Nein, wollte ich nur mal sagen. Weil der Trecker schon, deswegen performt er nämlich.
Ja, ja das tut er. So, worauf wollte ich jetzt hinaus? Also, ich deute das Ganze halt erstmal so ein bisschen als Flucht nach vorne. Das ist so ihr Plan B. Den hatten sie schon lange in der Schublade. Jetzt ziehen sie irgendwie die Register. Sie trennen einfach Trecker und Side und trennen damit einfach auch Dinge. Machen das auf der anderen Seite auch sozusagen auf einmal kommt dieses kommerzielle Interesse hoch. Das einzige, wo ich überhaupt keine Antwort drauf habe, ist diese Aussage aus dem Pressrelease des Verkaufs, dass sie eben jetzt mit Urheberrechten irgendwie da eine Lösung finden, wollen und auch, also nicht dagegen verstoßen wollen, mal kurz gesagt, und auch Vergütungsmodelle anbieten wollen.
Das ist ja dann aber auch eigentlich völlig total schnurzegal, weil dann ist die Pirate Bay halt eben nicht mehr ganz so, ja, weiß ich ob illegal das richtige Wort ist, aber dann gibt es halt keine Copyright geschützten Sachen mehr, weil sie die dann immer rausfiltern. Aber wenn der Trecker ja frei ist, dann gibt es da genug andere Seiten, also das ist eigentlich gar kein Problem.
Klar, gar keine Frage. Dieser Underground, der wird ja weitergehen und da werden sich irgendwie andere Suchmaschinen auftun und das wird halt irgendwie so sein.
Die wollen wahrscheinlich so den Mittelweg gehen, die wollen Geld verdienen und trotzdem legal bleiben. Oder kein Ärger.
Ja klar, aber jetzt frage ich mich, was bitte ist, was bitte sind diese Vergütungsmodelle? Okay, was gibt es jetzt noch für einen Aspekt? Wir haben diesen offenen Trecker, wir haben diese Stiftung, dessen Aufgabe so ein bisschen unklar ist. Wir haben die Zukunft dieser Webseite, die ist genauso unklar. Dann gibt es aber noch dieses kleine Detail, was die ganze Zeit dieser Diskussion übersehen wird und das ist halt diese Firma. Hattest du von der schon vorher gehört? Genau und die gehört mit zu diesem Deal und ich vermute mal, dass eben die Leute, die dort arbeiten, eben auch zu diesem Umfeld gehören. Und da heißt es ja, dass sie so an Next Generation Peer to Peer arbeiten. Und die einzige Interpretation, die ich dafür habe, ist, dass sie halt einfach an einer Erweiterung von Vittorrent arbeiten, die halt Checkerless arbeitet.
Da wäre ich noch skeptisch.
Na Peer to Peer 2.0, ich meine, was soll das sonst sein? Was blinkt denn hier?
Wüsste ich nicht, wer das da so macht. Also selbst Bram Cohn hat schon 2003 oder so Vittorrent 2.0 irgendwie in seinem Forum da erzählt. War es da schon alles so für Features Wort? Die hörten sich auch gerade ganz toll an, da ist bis heute noch nichts erschienen. Also es wird schwer, in diesem Peer to Peer-Sumpf irgendwie ein neues Protokoll hochzuziehen.
Naja klar, aber ich meine, wenn es irgendeiner kann, dann ist es Pirate Bay. Andererseits, wenn es jetzt Pirate Bay so nicht mehr gibt, ist die Frage, wie das nach vorne gehen soll. Also diese ganze Geschichte wirft derzeit mehr Fragen auf, als sie Antworten liefern kann. Trotzdem finde ich das sehr spannend. Und ich glaube schon, dass wir diese Aktivität, die sich derzeit so an den Pirate Bay Trecker manifestiert hat, die wird jetzt mit diesem Open-Bit-Torrent-Trecker irgendwie weitergehen, wer auch immer dafür jetzt verantwortlich sein wird. Die Frage ist natürlich, wo fliegen jetzt die Torrents rum, wenn sie nicht mehr bei Pirate Bay sind?
Ich glaube, Torrents verteilen, das ist noch das Leichteste. Aber Trecker zu haben, die halt offen sind und diese viel Last abkönnen, das ist nicht so easy. Also jeder kann sich so einen Rechner leisten, das ist gar kein Ding. Weil der ist halt so effektiv, den könnte man auf einem dicken Rechner irgendwie abfeuern. Aber man muss halt den Traffic bezahlen. Und ich glaube, das ist das größte Problem.
Na gut, ich meine, so mit Spenden hätte Abhalt B eigentlich nie wirklich ein Problem gehabt. Nur, dass sie das ja nie gemacht haben. Auch aus Prinzip.
Ist halt auch so ein Risiko, also da können halt auch mal...
Was?
Kann man schon auch mal nur für Betreiben eines Treckers Ärger kriegen.
Ja, das ist halt die Frage, inwieweit das jetzt auch wirklich hält, mit diesem Betreiben vom Trecker. Aber wenn halt die Sachen sowieso überdistributed... Ich meine, wenn alle Trecker dicht machen. So, angenommen Parabay-Trecker sind dicht, dieser Open-Bit-Torrent wird dicht gemacht und es gibt jetzt keine Trecker mehr, weil Sachen gemacht werden können. Und es gibt irgendwie eine Fascho-Internet-Police, die einfach jedem Server, der auch eine irgendwie Treckerartige Pakete annimmt, den Gar ausmacht. So, was passiert dann? Es wird sich entwickeln in Richtung IPv6, es wird sich entwickeln in Richtung Krypto, UDP-basiert und so weiter, weitgehend Stealth-Pakete und es wird sich entwickeln auf Distributed Hashtables, dass die sich halt einfach anders finden. Dass diese Trecker so nicht mehr notwendig sind. Ich stocke da auch selber so ein bisschen in der Suppe. Ich hoffe, dass ich das zur nächsten Sendung ein bisschen mehr weiß.
Ich denke auch, wir müssen mal kurz abwarten. Vielleicht ist es ja absichtlich, dass die nicht so viel Infos rausrücken, weil die haben halt nur mal einen Gerichtsverfahren am Hals.
Ja, also irgendwas ist da im Busch. Man muss sich mal genauer anschauen, was da so passiert.
Wir brauchen auf jeden Fall demnächst mal so was langsam wie ein Peer-to-Peer-DNS und Peer-to-Peer-Web.
Aber so ein spendenbasierter Trecker auf so einer legalen Insel wäre schon gar nicht so verkehrt.
Klar spendenbasiert.
Also für die Millionen Leute, die Pirate Bay benutzt haben, so viel spenden machen wir auch wieder nicht.
Was ich mir unter Legalisierungsübrigen noch vorstellen könnte, dass sie einfach sagen, den entsprechenden Content-Anbietern, hier habt ihr einen Teil von unseren Werbeerlösen.
Und dann?
Und dann sagen die entweder Ja oder Nee.
Dann sagen die natürlich Nee.
Wieso sollen sie Nee sagen?
Weil die Zahlen zu klein sind.
Besser als nichts.
Ja, so kommentieren sie aber nicht.
Sag, kommentieren sie nicht, aber so handeln sie unter Umständen. Wieso, wenn du aus einem Markt, der bisher noch gar keine Miliz hat?
Nur mit festen Verträgen und mit Planen. Und das geht nur nach ihrem.
Also wenn sie damit anfangen, würden ja auch tausende Trecker hochschießen bei allen Dingen. Ah, jetzt ist ja legal. Die würden keinen einzigen Film mehr verkaufen.
Also ich weiß nicht. Ich bin da sehr gespannt. Diese ganze Urheberrechtsgeschichte wird einfach noch mal sehr viel mehr Dynamik entwickeln in der nächsten Zeit, als das bisher schon der Fall war. So Leute, wir gehen jetzt die Gesprächs-Teamkarten aus. Ja.
Ich würde sagen, wir sind zweieinhalb Stunden. Wir sind alle ein bisschen müde, kann das sein?
Dann geh ich schon mal ins Bett und du kannst dich noch ein bisschen mit dem Internet unterhalten. Ich hab keinen.
Nicht?
Also Chat weiß auch nichts mehr, die schlafen glaub ich auch alle schon.
Also was ich hier noch hatte, das heute mal kurz darum ging, dass Nokia möglicherweise ja ein Android-Telefon behauen möchte.
Ach, dieses Gerücht.
Jetzt brechen sie ein. Microsoft sagt, sie machen jetzt einen auf Open Source.
Ja, was sie umgehend Hardcore auf eine Art und Weise dementiert haben, wie man nur dementieren kann, wenn man wirklich wirklich nichts damit zu tun haben will. Ich glaube.
Nee, also so schnell werden sie noch nicht öffentlich bekannt geben, dass sie dumm sind.
Meinst du, die entwickeln tatsächlich irgendwo ein Android-Phone?
Nein.
Die Einsicht noch nicht gewachsen. Obwohl, Nokia ist so ein monströs großer Konzern. Ich glaube, die wissen gar nicht, was sie alles tun.
Nokia ist das Microsoft-Telefonmarkt, oder?
Ja, ich meine, wenn sie auf Android gehen, also aus ihrer Position heraus, müssen sie Technologieführer werden. Das werden sie nicht schaffen, aber sie müssen es probieren. Dass sie zumindest noch ein bisschen mithalten können.
Na ja, aber man kann ja so sagen, also erstmal könnten sie es übernehmen, Android. Sie könnten ja was komplett Eigenes draus machen, was dann wieder propertär ist. Oder zumindest ein eigenes User-Unterface drauf packen. Zum zweiten muss man ja mal sagen, dass ich ja sehr viele Leute kenne, die sagen, Nokia hat zwar die widerlichste Software, die man sich nur vorstellen kann, aber die Hardware ist eigentlich super.
Bitte?
Gehörst du nicht auch zu diesen Leuten, die durchaus auch Gutes über die Hardware von deinem Nokia E71 oder so was gelassen haben? Außer das User-Unterface?
Na ja, das Gerät kann halt die ganze Zeit runterfallen und geht nicht kaputt. Aber das ist bei meinem iPhone jetzt auch nicht anders.
Ich sag auch so, die Hardware vom iPhone ist jetzt auch nicht so special. Die Kamera ist zum Beispiel schon so ein bisschen hinterher, was andere Telefone so haben, oder? Seh ich das richtig?
Ja, die neue nicht mehr.
Na, es gibt schon noch einiges besseres. Also ich meine, es gibt Kameras, die haben Blitz. Auch schon seit Jahren. Auch gute Blitz, Xenon-Blitzlicht, was wirklich was bringt. Nokia hatte eine Zeit lang auch wirklich so ein, die hatten quasi so ein quersitzendes Objektiv oben drauf, was dann richtig einen optischen Zoom hatte. Mit irgendwie absurden Megapixel-Zahlen. Was ein wirklich, wirklich gutes Bild gemacht hat. Außer, dass man beim Zoom nicht filmen durfte, weil dann hat man die Motorengeräusche mit auf Tape gehabt.
Was ich damit sagen will, ist, dass es halt nicht auf die Hardware ankommt, sondern auf die Software. Und deswegen ist es jetzt egal, ob Nokia tollere Hardware hat.
Es kommt schon auf beides an. Dieses Mehr-Feature ist für mich nicht automatisch bessere Hardware. Also das ist schon echt nochmal was anderes.
Sagen aber, Nokia-Geräte würden, das mag sich der Konzern selber noch nicht eingestehen, aber wahrscheinlich aus der Sicht von vielen Leuten doch durchaus gewinnen, wenn sie mit einem Android-Betriebssystem ausgeliefert werden würden.
Das weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube den Leuten ist dieses Betriebssystem wirklich scheißegal derzeit noch. Also die Leute, die Nokia kaufen, denen ist das Betriebssystem egal.
Meinst du nicht, dass die auch teilweise ganz gerne mal ein bisschen surfen würden? Ja, aber ich meine...
Ja, aber das Betriebssystem ist ihnen egal.
Ja, okay, die Leute, die Nokia kaufen, denen ist das Betriebssystem offensichtlich egal. Weil ansonsten würden sie nicht Nokia kaufen. Die Leute, die aber Nokia nicht mehr kaufen, denen ist das Betriebssystem unter und unter nicht egal.
Ja, also ich meine, es ist klar, seit längerer Zeit, seit diesem Symbian-Announcement und seitdem sie QT kaufen, was sie eigentlich vorhatten. So, iPhone kam hoch, sie sind komplett überrollt worden. Sie haben mittlerweile auch die letzte Spur von Marktanteil in Nordamerika komplett eingebüßt. Also sie sind einfach, muss man sich mal vorstellen, Nokia mag zwar der Weltmarktführer sein nach Stückzahlen, aber sie verkaufen keine, auch nur irgendwie nennenswerte Stückzahlen in Nordamerika überhaupt. Also in diesem ganzen Kontinent benutzt einfach niemand Nokia. Keiner. Da gibt es Symbian nicht. Da gibt es keine Installed Base, da gibt es gar nichts. Und sie sind nur in Europa, weil das ihr Home turf ist, und in Asien und was weiß ich, wo sie noch überall ihre Dinger noch gegen schmeißen, sind sie überhaupt präsent. Dann haben sie einfach eine ganze Batterie von sterbenden Betriebssystemen und User Interfaces, die sie jetzt alle schrittweise haben einstellen müssen, mit der speziellen Problematik, dass sie im Falle von Symbian eben auch noch in so einem völlig widerlichen Lizenzabkommen mit Sony Ericsson und Entity Docomo mit drinstecken, wo sie halt auch Verpflichtungen hatten. Und dieser ganze Klimpim mit Symbian wird jetzt Open Source und so weiter war nichts anderes als ein Abwicklungsstatement. Ja, so was sich ja jetzt auch zeigt. Ich meine, wer ernsthaft der Meinung ist, Symbian würde jetzt sozusagen, dadurch, dass es Open Source ist und modernisiert werden würde, konkurrenzfähig sein, versteht einfach nichts von Betriebssystem. Das ist halt einfach mal tot. So ich meine, wenn sie damit hätten was hinkriegen können, dann hätten sie genug Zeit. Da ist einfach gar nichts passiert.
Naja, muss man auch sagen, sie hatten auch lang genug nicht den Druck, was hinzukriegen.
Das ist genau der Fehler, man darf sie halt nicht auf seinen Lorbeeren ausfüllen.
Ja, aber ich glaube auch nicht, dass sie jetzt mit dem Druck irgendwas hinbekommen werden.
Ja, da glaube ich auch nicht so richtig dran.
Microsoft und Nokia kann man schon ein bisschen vergleichen, oder?
Dann haben sie halt Trolltech gekauft.
Genau. Was sie damit übrigens machen, lässt sich jetzt relativ einfach beantworten. Und zwar, das gibt es ja nach wie vor, haben sie ja ihre kleine Memo-Plattform. Dieses Linux für diese Nokia N700 und N800, also für diese Mini-Tablets. Und die werden jetzt umgestellt auf QG.
Ja, alles wird umgestellt auf QT. Sie stampfen alles ein. Symbian, alles was sie haben, ihren ganzen S30, 40, 50, 60, sonst irgendwie Unterscheidungsklimb. Sie wollen komplett auf Linux mit QT drauf, mit dem, ja ist das nochmal gleich bei Trolltech, diese Qtopia.
Und damals, da könnten sie nicht unten drunter auch einen Android packen?
Unten drunter nicht, nö.
Aber was ist denn unten drunter?
Weil Android ist ja oben drauf. Android ist ja nicht unten drunter.
Naja, aber ich meine, die werden schon, ja, aber die werden schon, Google wird schon einige Anpassungen gemacht haben, damit das halbwegs stromsparend auf der Plattform läuft, auf dieser AM-Plattform.
Das sollte Nokia auch machen.
Ja, das ist ja nicht das Problem, das ist eh Open Source. Das können sie sich einfach runterziehen bei Google.
Aber Android ist da hauptsächlich das Framework fürs GUI, oder?
Ja.
So, und dieses Cotopia ist da auch mal ein Framework.
Nicht nur fürs GUI, für die Applikationen. Das ist das Entscheidende. Das ist das Application Framework. Das ist das Äquivalent zu Coco.
Und auch zu Cotopia.
Genau.
Deswegen gibt da kein Android unter.
Ja, aber Android und Cotopia beziehungsweise Qt könnten unterschiedlicher nicht sein. Ich meine, das eine ist die Java-Welt, das andere ist die C++-Welt. Ja, das eine ist halt so wie Java funktioniert und im Falle von Android eben nochmal mit dem speziellen runtime environment von Google, was eben nicht von Xan ist. Und Qt ist halt quasi die KDE-Welt, mal ganz grob gesagt. So, deswegen ist auch dieses Myemo, Tod, Töter am Tötesten, weil das einfach die GTK-Welt ist. Das ist halt alles GTK-basiert.
Nee, nee, die wollen umstellen. Die wollen das System umstellen von GTK auf...
Ja, und umstellen heißt wegschmeißen.
Das heißt nicht nur wegschmeißen.
Ich sagte, die übernehmen ja nicht eine Zeile Code. Das ist einfach mal doomed. Die werden das komplett auf diesem ganzen Cotopia-Kram machen. Und da schrauben die jetzt auch schon seit 2, 3 Jahren dran rum. Weil die haben ja die Bude jetzt schon seit 2 Jahren. Oder? 2 Jahren, 1,5 Jahre, das ist noch nicht so lange her, aber ist auch jetzt schon einige Zeit vergangen, also auf jeden Fall ein Jahr. Na dann mal gucken, wann die irgendwie verkauft wurden.
Das war mit diesem Green Phone oder sowas, ne? Dann kurz danach.
Ja, ach so, die heißen ja jetzt auch gar nicht mehr Trolltechnik, die heißen jetzt QT Software, sehe ich gerade. Sparte von Nokia. So.
Das musst du schon zum Overmax-Zeiten gewählt sein.
2008, ok, also letztes Jahr war das. Aber wann denn eigentlich? 17. Juni, ok, also genau vor einem Jahr. Vor einem Jahr wurden die halt übernommen. So, jetzt gehe ich davon aus, dass sie halt übernommen wurden. Und im Wesentlichen war es halt das Software-Portfolio von denen, was sie eben schon hatten. Weil die haben ja im Prinzip schon Handys getargetet. Die haben laufende Software. Das ist ja nicht so eine Firma, die angekündigt hat, dass sie vielleicht irgendwann mal was fertig kriegt, sondern die delivern ja einfach schon seit geraumer Zeit.
Die haben jetzt schon ein fertiges Ziel.
Genau, das ist natürlich für die, warum es für die so interessant ist. Abgesehen davon, dass es halt auch Skandinavien ist. Und von daher passen die auch wunderbar zusammen. Bloß jetzt frage ich mich natürlich, where is the beef? Wo ist das scheiß Nokia-Telefon mit dieser QT-Software? Wo bleibt's? Ein Jahr und nichts ist passiert. Und alle Announcements sind immer nur, was sie hier und da hinschieben, was sie irgendwie noch droppen und fallen lassen. Es passiert einfach gar nichts.
Der Konzern hat einfach keine richtige Linie drin.
Ja, natürlich haben die keine richtige Linie drin. Es ist ja ganz offensichtlich, dass sie das nicht haben. Aber die Frage ist, kommt noch was? Also ich meine, hat es Sinn?
Da wird irgendwo eine kleine Unterabteilung, von der niemand so richtig Ahnung hat, wird da weiterhin wahrscheinlich ein Telefon-Prototyp nach dem anderen bauen, auf den dieses Cutie schon läuft. Genauso wie ihre Memo-Plattform da irgendwo halboffiziell durchgezogen ist. Ich glaube nicht, dass die da so eine Strategie hinter haben. Da haben sich wahrscheinlich innerhalb des Konzerns hoffenweise Abteilungen selbstständig gemacht. Und niemand weiß so richtig, was sie eigentlich den ganzen Tag über tun.
Ich glaube, dass sie einfach total verunsichert sind, in welche Richtung sie gehen sollen. Wenn du dir jetzt mal anschaust, mit welcher Geschwindigkeit Palm sein neues OS rausgehauen hat.
Das ist absolut, oder?
Was heißt Geschwindigkeit? Wer weiß, wie lange die daran schon umbasteln.
Na, dieses Kutupia, das gibt es schon seit ein paar Jahren.
Also ich nehme an, dass Palm angefangen hat, in dem Moment zu entwickeln, indem sie die, also so richtig angefangen, indem sie die Keynote von Apple gesehen haben. Die haben ja vorher auch richtig, richtig rumgedömert.
Also in welchen irgendwelchen Apple-Headerfiles steht, also fürs iPhone steht irgendwas von 2004, glaube ich. Da sind da schon echt lange dabei.
Das muss ja nicht bedeuten, dass der Kut zu dem Zeitpunkt auch schon spezifisch dafür gedacht war.
War eine iPhone-Appi fürs iPhone.
Na gut, aber das kann auch schon sozusagen ein internes Tablettprojekt gewesen sein.
Klar, also irgendwann haben sie halt angefangen, was auch immer das vorher war. Aber ich glaube, die Vorlaufzeiten sind ganz schön groß bei so einem Sachen. Wobei Nokia natürlich schon eine Weile im Geschäft ist. Apple muss natürlich alles frisch von vorne machen.
Ja klar, Vorlaufzeiten, aber Nokia hat keine Zeit zu verlieren. Die verlieren jetzt einfach im zweistelligen Bereich ja zu Jahr Marktanteile.
Zweistelligen Bereich?
Der Einbruch zum letzten Jahr war, was war das, 18% oder so?
Ich weiß nicht mehr so genau, im Smartphone-Bereich schon absurd.
Nicht im gesamten Bereich, sondern von ihrer eigenen Zahl runter. 18%.
Der Marktanteil der Weltweite.
Von ihrem eigenen?
Nein, vom Markt. Nein, nicht von ihrem eigenen Markt, da ist ja immer 100%.
Die hatten vorher irgendwann mal so...
Davon 18% weniger, das heißt, während drei Jahren wären sie ja weg vom Fenster.
Ja, sind sie ja auch.
Im Smartphone-Bereich hätten sie das Problem.
Ja.
Die sind in drei Jahren voll vom Fenster. Nokia, ich seh nicht, wie die sich noch retten wollen. Was sollen die machen? Die sind dermaßen durcheinander. Die haben nix. Die haben weder irgendwie kompetenten Hardware, die haben ja noch nicht mal eine einheitliche Hardware-Plattform. Ich meine, dass mal irgendwie das ein Telefon mal rauskommt, was über ein oder zwei oder drei Jahre für einen Developer eine halbwegs zuverlästige Plattform darstellt, dass sie sich mal auf Displaygrößen, APs, Prozessoren, Tastatur, eigentlich schafft sich irgendwas einigen.
Das war wahrscheinlich deren Problem, dass sie bisher immer ihre Telefone so irgendwie erstellt haben. Mit der Prämisse, so macht es irgendwie so, dass es geht, weil nächstes Jahr gibt es so wieder ein neues Telefon.
Ich denke einfach, dass sie einfach sehr viele unterschiedliche Teams haben, die parallel an irgendwelche Sachen dran arbeiten. Wir haben jetzt hier gerade noch mal so eine Pralinenkiste aufgemacht.
Das ist total lecker!
Echt? Das ist lecker?
Ich finde das großartig.
So eine schwarze?
Ich hatte eine rote, glaube ich.
Wir reden jetzt hier von Schokolade, ne?
Genau. So, aber jetzt nochmal zu meinem Thema Verunsicherung, warum sie unter Umständen auch noch jetzt wieder so lange brauchen, bis sie irgendwas rausbringen. Ähm, wegen Palm. Und weil Palm nämlich einfach sagt, also jetzt Apple im Bereich Arpies da irgendwie noch eine Kante zu pissen, so, was, ja, ich meine, glaubt man, glaubst du wirklich, dass man irgendwie mit C++ Developer auf eine Nokia-Plattform kriegt? Ich hab da so meine Zweifel.
Auf eine Nokia-Plattform schon, aber auf eine Plattform, die am Anfang auch quasi keine Verbreitung gaben wird.
Ja, so, und sie müssen ja auch erst mal ihren ganzen Symbian-Kram portieren. Also sie haben ja wirklich auch ein paar, naja, also Killer-Apps ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, aber wenn du dir anschaust, womit sie so werben und plakatieren, das sind halt vor allem ihre Navigationssachen, ihre Maps-Software. Muss dann auch auf dieser Plattform laufen, das heißt, sie müssen das irgendwie portieren, sie müssen das über eine Zeit lang auch auf mehreren Plattformen parallel weiterentwickeln. Das ist natürlich nicht einfach. Weil sie können jetzt nicht einfach irgendeinen Flagship rausbringen, sondern dann hat es noch nicht mal ihre Flagship-Applikation am Start. Das ist ein Bremser. Aber die andere Sache, warum ich Palm erwähnt habe, ist nicht, dass es Palm gibt oder so. Das wussten sie ja auch schon vorher. Sondern dass Palm halt auf JavaScript setzt. Dass das sozusagen ihre Ansage ist. Unsere Developmentsprache heißt JavaScript. Und das ist halt einfach etwas, wo du einen viel größeren Appeal hast an viele Leute als mit C++-Entwicklung.
Ja, man braucht nicht so viele Apis zu lernen.
Na gut, Apis werden da bestimmt noch so einiger zusammenkommen.
Klar, aber erst mal eine Seite kriegst du schon mal hin. Und das du ein Hello World auf dem Bildschirm stehen hast, ist halt ein No-Braner.
Als richtige vollwertige Applikations-Poemiesprache. Da musst du immer noch dieselben Sachen programmieren wie in C++. Aber du hast halt eine dynamische Scriptsprache, mit der du ganz einfach anders arbeiten kannst. Und JavaScript ist halt recht mächtig.
Ja, ich programmier den ganzen Tag JavaScript.
Ah, hier unser Schoko-Spender meldet sich gerade im Chat. Und er wundert sich, dass wir diese Lindor-Kugel noch gar nicht kannten.
Kann ich vielleicht noch mal gründlich zart schmelzend? Im Chat ging es schon rum.
Vielleicht wäre das ja mal eine potenzielle Sponsorenkategorie. Süßwarenhersteller. Ich hab mir eigentlich vorgenommen, ein bisschen abzunehmen.
Es gibt übrigens für Prowl auch eine API.
Das müssen wir jetzt um den Rest des Abends aufziehen, oder?
Erkennt gerne mal so ein Proll-Text-Theming für Mac OS X, wo dann die ganzen Ansagen nicht mehr so freundlich sind, sondern nur so voll prollig rüberkommen, irgendwie so. Äh, zieh mal den scheiß USB-Stick raus, du Arsch. So eine ganze vorgeschobene Freundlichkeit von diesen Betriebssystemen und so. Wir werden gefragt, ob wir Gummibären mögen.
Oh, was steht denn da?
Also ich werd's auch mal ausprobieren.
Mit einem simplen URL-Code ist es möglich, eigene Notifications anzuzeigen. Und das ist ja wirklich eine schicke Sache.
Ja, wollen wir jetzt noch die Hörer weiter damit quälen, dass wir hier diese Lindor-Kugeln essen? Oder wollen wir einfach mal hier ein Ende finden? Ich glaube, wir sind jetzt auch müde genug, morgen ganz, ganz, ganz früh aufzustehen und mich irgendwie in den Zug setzen. Ja, und das war's.
Jetzt wirklich.
Die 31, ja, wer hat an der Uhr gedreht? Wir haben immerhin schon wieder satte 2 Stunden und 40 Minuten zusammen bekommen. Und, naja, ja Leute, teilweise sogar mit Content.
Das war's.
Jetzt wollen sie wissen, wo ich hinfahre. Nichts von Datenschutz gehört oder was?
Frag doch einfach Tims Stromzähler.
Genau.
Ihr werdet es erfahren auf Twitter. Aber ich bin schneller wieder zurück, es lohnt sich überhaupt gar nichts zu erzählen, wo ich hinfahre. Na, ich bin mal wieder ein bisschen im Namen des Herrn unterwegs. Tschüss, ja bis bald und mobile.max auf Twitter. Da könnt ihr euch immer mal hinwenden. Erwartet nicht so viele Antworten, aber geht davon aus, dass wir das auch lesen und zur Kenntnis nehmen, was da so für Vorschläge kommen. So interessante Links, so Sachen, Geschichten, die man hier mal aufgreifen könnte und so weiter. Das ist immer ganz praktisch. Ja, und sonst haben wir doch schon Tschüss gesagt, oder? Haben wir schon Tschüss gesagt.
Wir haben uns ungefähr zwei Wochen gedreht. Ich hab so ein kleines Gadget auf der Seite eingebaut, wo man sieht, wann der nächste Termin ist. Ach wirklich? Ja, der sieht total hässlich aus, aber es steht halt drinne, dann und dann ist der nächste Termin.
Genau, mit dem Kalender, den könnt ihr auch abonnieren.
So, und jetzt ist Schluss.